GOOD AFTERNOON WE ARE COMMITTING
THE FULL BUDGET COMMITTEE
HEARING WE'RE HEARING SEVERAL.
CLEAN UP BILLS I HAVE A FEW NEW
TECHNICAL ISSUES TODAY.
O. IN ADDITION WE WILL BE VOTING
ON EACH BILL INCLUDING --
THREE BILLS WHICH OUR
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT LANGUAGE
ITEMS AND WILL BE HAVING PUBLIC
COMMENT AFTER EACH BILL.
SO WITH THAT WE WILL BEGIN WITH
S. B. EIGHT SIX TWO WHICH IS
AMENDMENT TO OUR BUDGET BELT
[inaudible]
BERMAN FINANCE.
THANK YOU CARL BECAUSE THE OTHER
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE I'M S. B.
EIGHT SIXTY TWO MAKES A NUMBER
OF AMENDMENTS TO THE BUDGET ACT.
IT LARGELY --
ADDS A REVISES ENCUMBRANCE
STATES IN LIQUIDATION DATES A
MIX IF YOU CORRECTIONS TO FISCAL
YEAR REFERENCES AND CODE
REFERENCES.
AND THEN PROVIDES A FEW --
FEDERAL FUND UPDATES THAT THE
GRANTS WERE PROVIDED AT THE
AFTER THE BUDGET ACT AS WILLIS A
FEW SPECIAL.
BUT APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS IN THE
CAN AND MISTER OBERNOLTE.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR SO
ORIGINALLY IS WRITTEN THIS
TRAILER BILL --
ALLOCATED UP TO AN ADDITIONAL
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS HAVE
UPON THE DMV'S REQUEST. TO BE
USED FOR REDUCING WAIT TIMES AT
FIELD OFFICES.
BY I'M LOOKING AT AN AMENDMENT.
HERE'S HAS AMENDMENT EIGHTEEN
WHICH I'VE HAD FOR AN HOUR --
CAN I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT THAT DID TO THAT TWENTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR CAP.
TECH CAN YOU EXPLAIN WHAT THAT
MEANT WHAT THE AMENDMENT DOES
NOW THAT DIFFERS FROM THE
ORIGINAL BILL.
SURE MARK NO PART FINANCE AND
YEAH THAT THE TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLARS WAS --
AN INITIAL ESTIMATE.
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE THERE'S A LOT
OF QUICK YOU KNOW [inaudible]
RESPONDING TREINTA.
I TRY TO SOLVE THE IN OTHERS WAY
TIME ISSUES THE DMV AND THAT WAS
IT A QUICK ESTIMATE I UNDERSTAND
THAT -- IN
THE END --
THE IN THE DISCUSSIONS THAT THAT
THAT DOLLAR AMOUNT WAS TAKEN OUT
AND WHAT'S REPLACED WITH IT IS
LANGUAGE THAT WELL --
REQUIRE THE DMV --
TO IDENTIFY THE REDUCTION
ASSOCIATED WITH WHATEVER
POSITION.
THEY COME IN WITH.
SO WHAT'S THE NEW CAP ON WHAT
THEY CAN ASK.
FOR THERE IT IS NOT CURRENTLY A
DOLLAR CAP IN.
IN THE LANGUAGE IT WOULD JUST BE
WHATEVER THINK I'M JUSTIFIED.
ANYTHING THEY ASK.
FOR ANYTHING THAT THEY JUSTIFIED --
OKAY THE ARMY DECLARE FIGHTS
UPON APPROVAL BY THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET.
SO IT'S NOT IT'S NOT A BLANKET
THE APPROPRIATION IT IS UPON
APPROVAL BY THE ALLEGED --
ACTUALLY MISTER CHAIR AFTER
RESPECTFULLY DISAGREE WITH YOU I
THINK THEY'RE REQUIRED TO NOTIFY
THE COMMITTEE IN THE LANGUAGE OF
THE BILL BUT I DON'T SEE
ANYWHERE IN THIS BILL THAT WE'RE
REQUIRED TO APPROVE IT.
AND THAT'S BY A BIG PROBLEM THAT
I HAVE WITH THIS AMENDMENT --
IT I THINK THE LEGISLATURE
PERFORMS A VITAL FUNCTION IN
SAFEGUARDING THAT MONEY AND
PROVIDING A LEVEL OF OVERSIGHT
OVER THAT MONEY.
AND ESPECIALLYIN LIGHT OF THE
HEARINGS THAT WE HAD LAST YEAR
WE ARE BUT YOUR LAST WEEK WE HAD
A BUDGET SUB SIX HEARING.
LAST WEEK AND THEN A JOINT
LEGISLATIVE AUDIT COMMITTEE
HEARING IN WHICH THE DMV
TESTIFIED THAT.
OTHER REALLY COULDN'T TELL US
WHY WE PAID SEVENTY MILLION
DOLLARS IN ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATION OF THEM TO REDUCE --
THE WAIT TIMES ARE FIELD OFFICES
IN OPEN SIXTY FIELD OFFICES ON
SATURDAYS.
ARE THEY OPEN SOME FIELD OFFICES
ON SATURDAYS LAST YEAR IN JAIL
THIS YEAR IN JANUARY AND THEN
CURTAIL THEM --
AND WHEN I ASK HOW MUCH MONEY
WAS LEFT THEY SAID NONE IT ALL
BEEN SPENT IN THE IF THEY
COULDN'T JUSTIFY YOU KNOW WHERE
THAT MONEY HAD GONE AND SO I
HAVE A BIG PROBLEM WITH.
GIVING THEM ESSENTIALLY A BLANK
CHECK --
WITHOUT ANY KIND OF LEGISLATIVE
OVERSIGHT --
AND I WISH I WAS I WAS ACTUALLY
LOOKING FORWARD TO VOTING YES ON
THIS -- WERE
ALL MOTIVATED TO TRY AND REDUCE
THOSE DO IT WITHOUT ANY KIND OF
ACCOUNTABILITY I THINK IS
MISGUIDED.
YOU KNOW MISTER OBERNOLTE AYE
AYE COMPLETELY ON CONCUR ON THE
LEGISLATURE APPROVAL OF NAFTA.
QUESTION GRIFFITH ACHIEVE
CONSULTORES.
COMMENT ON THE AMENDMENT NUMBER
EIGHTEEN WHICH YOU FRAUD REFER.
TO QUESTION GOV OTHER THE SOME
THE BUDGET MANY THE CONVENTION
OF JAIL BC WORKS IN SUCH A WENT
ONE WERE NOTIFIED IF THERE'S YOU
THERE'S A DATE AND THERE'S
THAT'S WHY THERE'S A CERTAIN
NUMBER OF DAYS THERE.
IN THE NOTIFICATION IF THE JAIL
PROCEED NON CONCURS.
WITH THE LATTER SENDS A LETTER
THIS IS THEY TALK OCCUR.
THE APPROACH BE ADDITIONAL
FUNDING WOULD NOT BE
APPROPRIATED AND SO THAT'S BEEN
THE CONVENTION WE FOLLOWED AND
THAT'S HOW WE'RE ABLE.
TO ALLOW FOR FUNDING TO BE ADDED
WHILE THE LEGISLATURE'S NON
SESSIONS TO THEIR CONTINUED BE
DISCUSSIONS OF THE INTENT OF
THIS LANGUAGE HERE.
IS TO NOT.
FRAME THE DMZ AUGMENTATION
AROUND A TWENTY SIX MILLION
DOLLAR FUNDING LEVEL IS TO FRAME
AROUND WHAT WOULD IT TAKE TO
REDUCE WAIT TIME SO THAT WE
ACTUALLY GET OUTCOME DIFFERENCE.
CHANGE THE OUTCOME FROM IN A
DIFFERENT DAY ADDITIONAL
APPROPRIATION AND THE
CONVERSATION TO BE THAT WAY
TIMES AS OPPOSED TO FRAMING.
THE ADDITIONAL ALLOCATION AROUND
AND NUMBER WHICH WITH THAT.
KIND OF LEAD TO THAT OUTCOME DID
HERE THAT YOU REFERENCED EARLIER
IN THE HEARING WHERE WE ADDED
MONEY WERE REALLY ABLE TO
UNDERSTAND HOW IT WOULD CHANGE
THE OUTCOME WHICH IS WHAT WHERE
REAL.
CONCERNS.
SO DO JUST GOOD JUST AND OTHER
DISTRICT REPLICATION DOWN.
WE HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
TWENTY SIX MILLION WITH THE
TWENTY SIX MONEY WAS THE CORRECT
NUMBER MAYBE WAVES HIGH MAYBE
WAS LOW.
BED --
EITHER WAY BASED ON THAT
PREVIOUS HEARING IT WAS CLEAR
THAT THEY HAD NOT BROUGHT FORTH
ENOUGH INFORMATION. TO JUSTIFY A
SPECIFIC APPROPRIATIONS SO
THAT'S WHY.
THE WE HAD ASKED THAT THEY COME
BACK AND BASICALLY COME BACK TO
US DURING RECESS AND THEN JAIL
PC COMMITTEE WAS THE ONLY WAY TO
DO THAT WHILE WE WERE.
WHILE WE WERE OUT.
OKAY I UNDERSTAND I I WOULD FEEL
A LOT MORE COMFORTABLE IF --
AN EXPLICIT APPROVAL FROM THE
LEGISLATURE WAS REQUIRED BECAUSE
WHAT YOU'VE SAID IS THAT IT'S
CONVENTION THAT ONCE THEY GIVE
US A NOTICE IF WE DISAGREE WITH
THAT WE CAN HOLD A HEARING.
BUT THAT'S NOT THEM IN THE
LEGISLATION DOES NOT SAY THAT WE
HAVE THE BILL NOW IF IF WE DON'T
CONCURRENT THAT IT WOULD THE
APPROPRIATIONS NOT OCCUR.
THAT'S THE CADETS A CONVENTION
FOR THE JOINT LEGISLATIVE BUDGET.
SO THAT IS WHY WE ARE ALLOWED TO
DO THIS BECAUSE WE DON'T WE
DIDN'T WANNA.
NAM NOT ALLOW THEM SOME
FLEXIBILITY BETWEEN NOW AND
JANUARY WHEN WE HE WANTED --
TO GIVE THEM THE OPTION TO COME
BACK TO THE LEGISLATURE WHAT WE
OKAY OUR I REALLY WISH THAT WE
HAD APPROVED ON AUDIT OF HOW
THAT MONEY WAS SPENT THE LAST
TIME WE NEED AN ALLOCATION.
LIKE THIS THAT WOULD GIVE ME A
LOT MORE COMFORT LEVEL THAT WE
COULD WRITE THEM ESSENTIALLY A
BLANK CHECK AND EXPECT THE
PROBLEM TO GET SOLVED IT ON A
PORCH I DON'T HAVE THAT COMFORT.
WHICH IS A SHAME BECAUSE I THINK
WE'RE ALL INCENTIVIZE TO TRY AND
SOLVE THIS PROBLEM.
LAW AGAIN JUST TO REITERATE THIS
COMMITTEE HAS COMPLETE AUTHORITY
TO REVIEW THE APPROPRIATIONS
THAT WE DID AND SO ON IF THERE
ARE CONCERNS REGARDING THAT --
MORE THAN HAPPY TO MEET WITH YOU
AND DISCUSS ABOUT HOW THIS
COMMITTEE CAN PURSUE THAT.
BUT WITHOUT MISS MELINDA'S.
BEFORE YOU CAN WE KALRA.
KILEY KALRA PERSONAL
[inaudible]
TING [inaudible]
OBERNOLTE [inaudible]
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
BLOOM.
BROWN HAIR CARRERA [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CHOI COOPER.
FONG HERE HARPER.
JONES SAWYER KALRA.
LACKEY HERE.
MATHIS THEIR MCCARTY MEDINA AIRS
MELENDEZ.
MULLIN MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO
[inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
VOEPEL [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WHAT?
THANK YOU THIS MONTH'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN UP SO.
THE VICE CHAIR ALREADY ASKED
MOST OF THE QUESTIONS THAT WERE
ON MY MIND I JUST WANTED TO KNOW
IF THERE'S ANY SORT OF I GUESS
REPORT.
THAT REYES RECORDER STANDARD
THAT IT THAT IS SET TO THAT --
WE UNDERSTAND WHICH DMV OFFICES
WILL BE.
INSTITUTING HOURS ON SATURDAY OR
OVER YOU NO LONGER HOURS IS IS
THIS UNIFORM ACROSS ALL DMV
OFFICES IN THE STATE.
HOW IS THAT DECIDED?
YES THE DMP IS--
DIRECTING A NEW STAFF TO THE
OFFICES WITH THE THE GREATEST
NEED.
AND DUMB AND THE LANGUAGE AS AN
INTENDED TO REPORT ON EXACTLY
HOW THAT WAS DONE SO --
SAID THEY'LL DECIDE WHICH
OFFICES HAVE THE GREATEST NEED
AND THEN ASSIGN SATURDAY HOURS
OR ADDITIONAL HOURS DURING THE
WEEK TO THE TOPS IS THAT RIGHT
[inaudible]
NOTICING.
WELL YES --
AND ALSO THE STAFF ASSOCIATED
WITH THOSE [inaudible]
OKAY BECAUSE I JUST --
IN GOING THROUGH.
ALL OF THE DIFFERENT DMV OFFICES
AND SAYING THERE.
REALLY I CAN'T FIND ANY THAT
DON'T HAVE KIND ENOUGH OF A LONG
WAIT SO I'M I'M CONCERNED THAT
THERE MAY BE SOME OFFICES IN
THIS STATE THAT WON'T GET THOSE
EXTRA HOURS THAT REALLY NEED
THEM JUST AS MUCH AS YOU KNOW
SOME OF THE OTHER COUNTY SAN
TURN FORGET.
HOW WE MAKE THAT FAIR AND
EQUITABLE ACROSS THE STATE IF
IT'S GOING TO BE --
SOMEWHAT ARBITRARILY DECIDED BY
THE DEPARTMENT ITSELF --
DOES THAT MAKE SENSE AND I DON'T
KNOW I MEAN I I'M NOT TRYING TO
THIS ISN'T A GOTCHA THIS IS
GENUINE CONCERN THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE SOME AREAS OF THE STATE
THAT WILL BE.
YOU KNOW STILL WAITING IN A VERY
LONG LINES ARE HOW DO WE MAKE
SURE THAT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN IF
WE'RE GOING TO ALLOCATE.
ESSENTIALLY --
UNLIMITED FUNDS TO THE EXTENT
THAT IT IS ASKED FOREIGN
JUSTIFIED FOR THAT PART I THINK
IT'S ARE COMPLETELY APPROPRIATE
AND DOWN
IN A VERY VERY GOOD QUESTION AND
FACT THE QUESTION I ASKED --
W. DIRECTOR WHEN I MET WITH.
HIM ON MONDAY WOULD BE HAVING
FURTHER CONVERSATIONS WOULD
WELCOME ANY MEMBER ON THE BUDGET
COMMITTEE OR ANY MEMBER OF THE
ASSEMBLY IF THEY WANT TO JOIN IN
ON THOSE DISCUSSIONS HAPPY.
TO ON THE DE DEPUTY COULD NOT
SPECIFY EXACTLY THE METHODOLOGY
THAT I ASKED EXACT IN QUESTION.
HOW DID YOU CHOOSE WHERE YOU
ALLOCATE RESOURCES?
WHAT ARE THEY DOING ON THE HEAT
HE DID SHOW ME?
THAT BASED ON THEIR BEST
CALCULATION OF WAIT TIMES WHERE
THERE WERE WITH THE WORST WAIT
TIMES WHICH WERE NOT WHICH OF
THE MORE THAN HAPPY TO ENCOURAGE
HIM TO SHARE WITH.
SO THEY CAN GET A KIND OF OF A
GAS OF WHERE WHERE THINGS ARE --
HAVING THE MOST PRESSURE BUT
HAVING SAID THAT I THINK IT'S ON
ACTUALLY PROPER THAT WE CONTINUE
TO FOLLOW UP AND UNDERSTAND HOW
THESE RESOURCES ARE DEPLOYED.
SO THAT AGAIN THESE WAIT TIMES
WHICH AGAIN ARE STATEWIDE ISSUE
CAN BE ADDRESSED ACROSS THE
BOARD SUB POP UPS LOW AND AGAIN
IF YOU'RE INTERESTED HAPPY --
TO INCLUDE ANYONE AND FURTHER A
PROPER [inaudible]
PART [inaudible]
MR MATHIS.
SO MY MY QUESTION GOES ALONG
SOME THE SAME LINES.
I ACTUALLY REACHED OUT TO THE
DMV OFFICE AND SAID I WANT TO
SIT DOWN AND NO ACTUALLY OTHER
CONVERSATION ABOUT A WHAT.
WHAT D. V. ACTUALLY NEEDS TO TO
HELP GET THEM IN FIX SOME OF
THESE PROBLEMS?
ON PART OF THE CONVERSATION
INVOLVED KIOSK --
THE FACT THE THE OTHER SEVERAL
OCCASIONS WITH KIOSK IN THERE'S
HIGH PROPENSITY AREAS THAT DON'T
HAVE KIOSK --
IN IN I THINK THE THE CHAIR
CHYNA ANSWER PART OF THE
QUESTION FOR YOU INSANE YOU YOU
GUYS DON'T KNOW WHERE.
THE RESOURCES ARE ACTUALLY GONNA
GO BUT IT BUT I'D LIKE TO NOW
YOU KNOW HOW MANY KEY OSCAR
GASOLINE UPSWING IN --
EXTENDING HOURS A IN IN THESE
THINGS BLADE CURRENT FROM THE
ANSWERS WERE GETTING --
APPEAR ALREADY TODAY YOU GUYS
SEEM TO NOT KNOW THOSE.
I MEAN CAN YOU.
SEAN SOME LIGHT ON THAT A LITTLE
BIT MORE.
YES I THINK SO IN TERMS OF THE
KIOSKS THAT YOU'RE REFERRING TO
THESE ARE THE AUTOMATED --
YES SELF SERVICE TERMINALS WE
CALL THEM --
AND SO THE OTHER NUMBER OF THEM
IN DMV OFFICES AND THEN A FEW
YEARS AGO WE'VE BEEN BEGIN
PUTTING THEM IN RETAIL
ESTABLISHMENTS.
AND SO THERE IS A A PROCESS FOR
THAT.
I THINK IN TERMS OF USING THOSE
KIOSKS --
IT'S SIMILAR TO WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO PUT THE WORD THE DMV IS
GOING UP POSITIONS --
THE TREND OVER ADDRESS WHERE
WHERE THAT'S GOING TO WORK BEST
SOCIALS PART OF THE THE PROCESS
IN THE PLANNING WITH THIS --
UNLIMITED FUN THAT YOU GUYS ARE
ASKING FOR IS.
TO IMPROVE MAYBE SOME OF THOSE
KIOSK IN RETAIL OUTLETS IN IN
THOSE THINGS AS WELL.
AS HAVE BEEN DISCUSSED.
I BELIEVE SO YES.
THE DEBATE IN THAT MEETING THAT
I HAD ON MONDAY THE DEPUTY
DIRECTOR DID --
THAT MISTER CHAIRMAN ON ALL OF
US WERE IN THEM MEANING IN THIS
I'M TWENTY AND YOU'RE ABOUT
CRIED DOMINATE YOUR QUESTION ON
THIS RIGHT.
GO FOR MY QUESTIONS FOR THEM
SURE MISTER CHAIRMAN THAT'S FUN
THINKING THAT.
THAT THEY DO HAVE A SPECIFIC
PLAN FOR KIOSKS ON MY
UNDERSTANDING IS THAT --
THEY LOOK AT A CONTRACT AND ARE
EXPANDING THOSE OPTIONS ARE
AROUND THE STATE AND THEY HAVE
NOT THEY DID NOT TELL ME EXACTLY
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO BE
DEPLOYED.
BUT THEY HAVE MORE THAT WILL BE
AND THEN YOU AT I JUST THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT THE PUBLIC KNOWS.
WHEN IT WHEN IT WHEN THEY'RE
MEETING WHEN HE WAS CHAIRMAN IT
IT DOESN'T GET OUT TO THE PUBLIC
ON WHAT THESE PLANTS ARE?
IN A ANY IT'S IMPORTANT FOR OUR
PUBLIC ESPECIALLY WITH WITHOUT
HAVING AN AUDIT.
AND IN HAVING THESE THINGS IN IN
TALKING ABOUT DOING THIS LATER
ONE OR NOT IN SESSION AND I
THINK FOR A LOT OF OUR PUBLIC
SOURCE OF MY CONSTITUENTS.
THE SHEET IS IT BEING DONE --
AND IN THE DARK OF NIGHT AND NOT
BEING A LOT OF TRANSPARENCY AND
SO I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE THAT
ARE UPSET.
BECAUSE IT'S HAPPENING THAT WAY
THE INFORMATION IS NOT GETTING
OUT AND THEN WITH THE AUDIT NOT
HAPPENING THERE'S EVEN MORE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE BEING ASKED.
SO IT MAKES IT VERY DIFFICULT TO
SEE WHAT'S ACTUALLY HAPPENING
WITH OUR DMV IN WITH.
OUR TAXPAYER DOLLARS GOOD GOOD
WITH MORE WHICH IS WHY CHAIR
THAT HEARING ALL LAST WEEK --
WE WILL HAVE ADDITIONAL FOLLOW
UP HEARINGS AND I BELIEVE THAT --
BASED ON THIS IT'S TO COME IN ON
US AS AS MESSENGERS TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS TO TRY.
TO LIKE GET THATINFORMATION OUT
TO THE PUBLIC AS WELL SO I I
COMPLETELY IT OCCURRED CURRENT
THAT THERE NEEDS TO BE.
FAR GREATER TRANSPARENCY GREATER
OPENNESS AND COM I'M GLAD YOU
AGREE ON TRANSPARENCY LOOK FOR
TO THAT ON IT [inaudible]
MR FUNG.
I THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN --
I THINK THE HESITANCY I THINK A
LOT OF US TO ACTUALLY APPLY THE
CHAIRMAN FOR FOR HIS PUSH FOR
PLAN.
AS IS THAT VERY REASON WE'RE
LOOKING FOR A PLAN FROM THE DMV
I KNOW THAT THERE'S FOCUS ON
KIOSKS FOCUS ON STAFF TO FOCUS
ON RESOURCE IS THERE.
A COMPREHENSIVE PLAN THAT THE
DMV IS GOING TO PROVIDE US.
SO THAT WE CAN EVALUATE THAT
ALONG WITH WITH ANY FUNDING
REQUESTS TO TO ACTUALLY
DETERMINE WHETHER.
THE FUNDING AND THE PLAN WORKS.
I WOULD SAY YES IF --
WE GOING TO THE PROVISIONAL
LANGUAGE IT'S BEING --
CONSIDERED HERE --
IT PROVIDES FOR THAT SORT OF
REPORTING AND THE DESCRIPTION
INTO FROM THE DEPARTMENT ABOUT
HOW THEY'VE USED THAT.
WE HOPE RESOURCES THEY'VE
RECEIVED SO FAR AND HOW THEY'RE
GOING TO USE TO NEW RESOURCES
WHERE THEY'RE GOING TO BE SO
THIS SO THIS PLAN HAS TO BE
PRODUCED AND IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE FUNDING REQUEST.
YES AND WHAT METRICS ARE THEY
USING A ME IS.
IS THERE A SPECIFIC WAY TIME
THAT INTERNALLY THEY NEED TO
MEET IS IT FIFTEEN MINUTES IS IT.
THIRTY MINUTES OVER WHAT WHAT
METRICS ARE THE UTILIZING
[inaudible]
I'M.
SO IN TERMS OF MEET YES IT'S
COULD TELL BASED ON WAIT TIMES --
HISTORICALLY THEIR TARGET HAS
BEEN IF YOU HAVE AN APPOINTMENT --
THAT YOUR AND IF YOU DO NOT HAVE
AN APPOINTMENT YOUR SEEN WITHIN
FORTY FIVE MINUTES NOT TO SAY
THAT.
SAID THAT THE IDEA IS TO MAKE IT
AS QUICK AS POSSIBLE THAT THOSE
THOSE KIND OF BEEN THEIR TARGET
WAIT TIMES.
AND SO --
THOSE WAIT TIMES HAVE GROWN
CONSIDERABLY AND THEIR GOAL IS
TO GET BACK TO THAT --
AS AND SO THAT'S YOU KNOW TERMS
OF IT'S NOT THAT AND UP.
AT ANOTHER THERE'S A WOULD LIKE
TO GET DOWN TO AN HOUR IF YOU
HAVE AN APPOINTMENT THEY'RE
TRYING TO GET BACK TO THAT
[inaudible]
SO THEN. FOR US AS THE
LEGISLATURE AND FOR THE CHAIRMAN
IS THAT IT'S A WE CORRECT INTO
TO EVALUATE THE DMV BASED ON
THOSE WAY TYPES SO IF THEY WERE
TO REQUEST.
AN AMOUNT OF MONEY WE SHOULD
EVALUATE THEIR SUCCESS OR
INABILITY TO ACHIEVE THOSE WAIT
TIMES BASED ON THE FIFTEEN
MINUTE.
OR WHATEVER CRITERIA THAT THEY
BALLOT.
I WOULD SAY THAT DOES WAIT TIMES
THAT'S WHAT THEY HAVE TESTIFIED
AS BEING THERE STANDARD THAT'S
KIND OF THAT THE BAR THEY HOLD
THEMSELVES.
TO BUT AND SO THE WAY THIS
LANGUAGE IS WRITTEN.
ANY AUGMENTATION THIS WAS TO
IDENTIFY --
HOW HOW IS THIS REDUCING THOSE
WAIT TIMES?
SO AND ASK THE QUESTION DEVOID
OF I THINK IT'S IT'S A I'M I'M
BEING A LITTLE I'M NOT I GUESS
I'M BEING MAYBE A LITTLE
CONFUSING THAT SHOULD BE.
HOW DOES THE DMV DEFINE SUCCESS?
I WOULD BE.
IN IN IN OTHER HEARINGS I THINK
THEY HAVE TESTIFIED THAT.
IN TERMS OF WAIT TIMES THEIR
SUCCESS IS MEETING THAT FIFTEEN
MINUTES AND FORTY FIVE MINUTE
TIMEFRAME.
AND SO --
DID WHEN THEY ASK FOR NAY
RESOURCES THEY'LL HAVE TO BE
EXPLAINING HOW THEY'RE GOING TO
YOU KNOW WHAT WHAT THE CURRENT
WAIT TIME IS.
AND HOW THOSE RESOURCES ARE
GOING TO REDUCE THAT WAIT TIME
AND BY HOW MUCH OKAY BECAUSE I
THINK THE CHAIRMAN IS CORRECT
ASK FOR PLAN I JUST WANT TO BE
ABLE TO EVALUATE ARE ALL OF US
SHOULD BE ABLE TO EVALUATE THAT
PLAN.
BASED ON WHAT IT SHOULD BE AND
SO IF IT'S FIFTEEN MINUTES AND
FORTY FIVE MINUTES AND THEY'RE
ASKING. FOR TWENTY SIX MILLION
OR WHATEVER THE NUMBER IS THAT
IF THEY DON'T MEET THAT THEN
THEY SHOULD BE UP FRONT AND SAY
THEY DIDN'T MEET THAT AND THAT
THEY SHOULD REEVALUATE THEIR
PROCESS.
MY CORRECT TO ASSUME THAT.
WELL YES IN THAT WELL.
I WOULD SAY YES [inaudible]
BUT IF THEY WERE TO COME IN FOR
REQUEST SAFER TWENTY SIX MILLION.
AND IT'S X. NUMBER OF POSITIONS
AND THEY WOULD BE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY --
WHAT THAT HOW THAT'S BRINGING
DOWN THE WAIT TIME AND SO I
DON'T KNOW THAT THIRTY SIX
MILLION DOLLAR NUMBERS THE RIGHT
NUMBER --
BUT WHATEVER THAT DOLLAR IS IT'S
GOING DEL VALLE YES IT WILL TELL
YOU WHERE THEY'RE GONNA GO AND
WHAT THE BY HOW MUCH THEY
ANTICIPATE THAT REDUCING WAIT
TIMES OKAY Y. I LOOK FORWARD TO
THE CHAIRMAN'S FUTURE HEARINGS
AND LOOK FOR THEM TO DEFINE.
HOW THEY'RE GOING TO GET TO
FIFTEEN A FORTY FIVE MINUTE WAIT
TIMES?
I THINK IT WAS BLOOM.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR --
AND I WOULD LIKE TO BE PART OF
THOSE DISCUSSIONS THAT --
THAT YOU REFERENCED --
EARLIER AND AND LIKE A CHAIR
BUDGET SUB THREE THAT HAS
OVERSIGHT OVER --
AT THE AT DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES.
ON A I REGRET THAT I WASN'T AT
THE HEARING.
LAST WEEK I WAS TOURING --
THE INCIDENT COMMAND CENTER OF
THE OF THE CAR FIRE.
THAT DAY AND UNFORTUNATELY
WASN'T ABLE TO MAKE IT CAUGHT
FIRE BEING ANOTHER ONE OF THE
DEPARTMENTS THAT --
THAT WE OVERSEE AND I I WOULD
LIKE.
TO SAY THAT THE DEPARTMENT OF
MOTOR VEHICLES TRADITIONALLY HAS
BEEN ONE OF THE HIGHER
PERFORMING DEPARTMENTS THAT WE
OVERSEE --
AND SO I SEE THIS --
A CURRENT SITUATION AS AN
ABERRATION FROM FROM THE NORM
AND SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
RELATIVELY --
ARE EASY TO CORRECT --
A WE KNOW WHAT A OF SOME OF THE
CAUSES ARE --
FOR THE DELAYS OR WAS IT --
AND AYE IT CLEARLY IT WAS NOT --
THE EXTENT OF THE WORKLOAD WAS
NOT PROPERLY ANTICIPATED BY BY
THE DEPARTMENT BUT WITH RESPECT
TO THE QUESTION ABOUT --
WAIT TIMES AS A METRIC OF EVERY
TIME THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES COMES AND IT PROVIDES --
THEIR UPDATE TO US THEY ALWAYS
TELL US ABOUT WAIT TIMES AS
BEING ONE OF THEIR METRICS AND
I'M QUITE CERTAIN THAT THEY WILL
DO THAT AGAIN BUT THEY ALSO TALK
ABOUT.
CUSTOMER SERVICE AS A AS A
METRIC A AT THE NUMBER OF
CUSTOMERS THAT THEY'RE ABLE TO
SERVE.
THE FEEDBACK THAT THEY THAT THEY
GET FROM CUSTOMERS AND THIS IS
SO ONE OF OUR DEPARTMENTS THAT
INTERFACES WITH THE PUBLIC MORE
SO THAN --
THAN MOST --
AND IT'S GOOD THAT QUE OUR
CUSTOMER CENTRIC AND WE WANT TO
ENCOURAGE THEM AND REQUIRED THAT
WE WANT TO MORE THAN ENCOURAGED
IN ONE WEEK.
CHOIR THEM TO TO BE THAT WAY AND
AND A LIKE I SAID THEY HAVE --
I REALLY MET THE MARK AND THE
FEEDBACK THAT I'VE RECEIVED OVER
TIME UNTIL NOW HOW ABOUT --
ABOUT THE DEPARTMENT HAS BEEN --
VERY POSITIVE PARTICULARLY
COMPARED TO YEARS AGO WHEN --
I DON'T THINK IT'S ANY SECRET OF
THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES
WAS -- NOT
SEEN IT WAS IT WAS YOU KNOW WAS
SEEN AS THAT PLACE WHERE YOU
WOULD GO ONE WAY AND NEVER GET
SERVE TEN AND AND WITH --
I DON'T THINK WATCHES CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR VEHICLES BUT
THIS WAS ONE OF THE DEPARTMENTS
THAT WAS THE* OF MANY JOKES --
ABOUT -- A
BUREAUCRACY AND WAIT TIMES AND
THEY REALLY --
TURNED THAT AROUND SO IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT THIS.
UNDER CURRENT CIRCUMSTANCES IT
EXISTS UP WE WILL APPROVE BE
PROVIDING ADDITIONAL OVERSIGHT
HAD OVER THE DEPARTMENT IN THE
COMING BUDGET CYCLE --
I'M QUITE CERTAINLY THAT CERTAIN
THAT WE WILL EXPAND OUR HEARING
TIME FROM A WHAT WE NORMALLY DO
WHICH IS A RELATIVELY SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME AND PERHAPS --
A RESERVE IN ENTIRE HEARING SO
THAT WE CAN PERFORM SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT OVERSIGHT AND TO
PROVIDE TRANSPARENCY.
THAT -- OF
THAT THE PUBLIC SO THAT IS
SOMETHING GOT --
THAT WE WILL --
DEFINITELY UNDERTAKEN THE COMING
BUDGET CYCLE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU DOCTOR EVER.
YES -- I WAS
AT THE HEARING AND AND I THINK --
AND IT'S GOOD TO KNOW THAT
OBVIOUSLY WHERE WE'RE ASKING FOR
TIME AND I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF
THE CONCERNS I HAD AS TO HOW
SOON SHOULD WE SEE.
THE RESULTS OF THE LOVE OF THE
INFUSION OF DOLLARS OF DOLLARS
ARE PLACED INTO THIS AGAIN.
THE OTHER THING IS THAT THERE
ARE OFTEN WE'VE ALREADY CREATED
SOME PROBLEMS THAT EXIST IN IT
AND I WAS TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHETHER NOT WERE ACTUALLY GOING
TO RESPOND TO THOSE PARTICULAR
PROBLEMS NOW.
WHAT I'M HAD TO DO WITH PEOPLE
TRYING TO GET APPOINTMENTS?
AND THE POINT WAS WILL COMING
AFTER THE DATE THAT THEY WOULD
DO TO BE --
ALL THEIR DAY TO GET THE LICENSE
AND I KNOW THERE WAS SOME
DISCUSSION THAT WE WERE THINKING
OF DOING. EIGHT EIGHT THIRTY TO
SIXTY DAYS [inaudible]
DELAY. FOR SOME OF THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AND THAT IS THAT
HAPPENING OR NOT I I HEARD IT AS
A DISCUSSION I HAVEN'T SEEN IT
AS A PLAN.
OF MAY BECAUSE AFFECTS ME
PERSONALLY JUST GOT MY RENEWAL
AND TRY TO GET APPOINTMENTS AND
IT'S OCCURRING A MONTH AFTER MY
STUFF IS DO YOU.
THAT SAID I DON'T ONE OF YOU
FACE THE DMV BUT OBVIOUSLY I
MIGHT BECOME SO I'M TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT WHAT THE WE HAVE.
MADE AN EFFORT TO TRY TO CORRECT
SOME OF THE PROBLEMS THAT WE
CREATED OR THAT WERE CREATED AS
A RESULT OF THE OF OF WHAT'S
GOING ON HAVE WE DONE THAT.
YES AND SO ON I THINK THAT --
THE DISCUSSION YOU REFERENCE
SCENE HAD TO DO FIRST OF ALL
WITH WITH BILLING AND SO --
THAT ARE MOTOR VEHICLES NORMALLY
SENDS OUT BILLS --
AND AND LIKE YOUR RENEWAL NOTICE
FOR EXAMPLE WOULD GO OUT NINETY
DAYS BEFORE IT'S DUE --
AND STICK DEBT WITH THE TO GIV
YOU TIME.
TO RESPOND AND AND A SCHEDULED
APPOINTMENT THAT IS BEING --
CHANGE TWO HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS SO THEY'RE IN THE PROCESS
OF EXTENDING THAT OUT SO
EVERYBODY WILL GET THEIR RENEWAL
NOTICES A HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS IN ADVANCE.
WHICH IS INTENDED TO CREATE
ENOUGH TIME THERE FOR CUSHION
FOR OF THOSE APPOINTMENTS.
BUT THIS DIDN'T HAPPEN OF THESE
NOTICES AND NOT GO OUT NINETY
DAYS IN ADVANCE THE ONE THAT I
RECEIVED.
SO AS A RESULT IS MORE LIKE
FORTY FIVE DAYS SO YOU APPLY --
FOR TO GET AN APPOINTMENT AND
ONLY TO DISCOVER THAT THE
APPOINTMENT WILL COME.
UP THIRTY OF FORTY DAYS AFTER IT
SUPPOSED TO HAVE BEEN SO YOU
LICENSE WILL EXPIRE AND OF THE
WORDS BEFORE YOU HAVE RENEWAL SO
YOU HAVE THE CHOICE.
OF EITHER GOING AND STANDING IN
LINE FOR EVER AND TRYING TO GET
IT DONE.
OR HAVING AN EXPIRED LICENSE
WHICH ALWAYS CREATED MORE
PROBLEMS SO I KNOW WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT IT BECAUSE I WAS
ONE OF THE CONCERNS OF THE
COMMITTEE THAT.
THAT THE NOTICES HAD GONE OUT.
NINETY AND SO WHEN PEOPLE THEN
WENT ON THE LINE TO TRY TO GET
AN APPOINTMENT TO MAKE IT EASIER
TO GREEN OF THEIR LICENSE.
THAT THEY WOULD BE BASICALLY
WHAT THE DATE PASSED THE
DEPRESSED THE EXPIRATION DATE SO
THE QUESTION IS AND I KNOW WAS
SOME DISCUSSION THAT WE WERE
GOING TO LOOK AT THAT.
AND TRY TO CORRECT THAT
SITUATION BECAUSE THAT'S THAT'S
THAT'S A SITUATION FOLKS IN NOW
VERY FRUSTRATED BECAUSE THEY
TRYING TO GET A DATE AND IT'S
NOT HAPPENING.
AND GOT AND SO THEY'RE GOT THESE
RENEWAL DATES BEYOND THE
EXPIRATION DATE --
AND AND THERE WAS A NINETY DAYS
THAT THAT INPUTS THEY RECEIVE
THEIR WE KNOW LICENSE AND AND
BILLING.
SO HAVE WE GRAPPLE WITH THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT IT BUT I GUESS IT
DIDN'T HAPPEN AFTER THE LAST
HEARING.
WELL IN TERMS OF DMV'S PROCESS
IS THERE IN THE PROCESS OF OF
SWITCHING OVER TO THE I DON'T
EXACTLY WHAT DAY IT PAID DINNER
WILL HAPPEN THERE SWITCHING OVER --
TO SENDING OUT. FOR OUR RENEWAL
NOTICES ONE HUNDRED AND TWENTY
DAYS IN ADVANCE.
RIGHT BUT YOU GOT SOME PEOPLE
WHO HAVE ALREADY RECEIVED
NOTICES THAT WERE NOT A HUNDRED
AND TWENTY NOR NINETY DAYS IN
ADVANCE.
AND THEY ARE NOW IN A SITUATION
BECAUSE OF THE THE ONSLAUGHT OF
FOLKS TRYING TO GET IN THERE
THAT THEY ARE THERE'S LICENSE
WILL EXPIRE.
BEFORE THEY CAN GET AN
APPOINTMENT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF WE WOULD
ALWAYS.
AS THE OTHER IS THAT SOMEONE
ASKED ABOUT THAT NICK WAS IT
HAPPEN TO ME IS I'M IN THE SAME
SITUATION --
SOUL OR IS OUR ONLY SOLUTION TO
GO STAND IN LINE.
BECAUSE NO MATTER HOW MANY
PEOPLE YOU CALL DMB YOU GET A
RECORDING SO IT'S NOT GONNA
HAPPEN -- SO
YOU'RE CONSTANTLY COMPUTER
PUSHING A BUTTON THAT GIVES YOU
DATES AND EVEN FURTHER THAN THE
FIRST DAY.
SO.
WHAT'S THE SOLUTION TO THE
PRODUCT I DO KNOW WE WHEN WE AND
THE SOMEONE IT SAID THEY WERE
THINKING OF DOING EXTENSION. FOR
THOSE THAT ARE BETTER BEEN
CAUGHT IN THIS RIGHT NOW BUT
OBVIOUSLY WE HAVEN'T DECIDED ON
THAT.
WELL I KNOW THAT THEY ARE
CONSIDERING THAT AND A PROCESS
FOR AS EXTENSIONS I DON'T HAVE
THAT INFORMATION RIGHT NOW I
COULD FOLLOW UP.
OKAY WHO WOULD HAVE THE
INFORMATION.
DEPARTMENT MOTOR VEHICLES.
LET ME ANSWER THE PHONE.
OKAY SOUND LIKE A PLAN
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
THIS MATHIS [inaudible]
SO.
SO SOME UNDERSTANDING YOU
CORRECTLY YOU GUYS PRIDE
YOURSELVES ON CUSTOMER SERVICE.
RIGHT IT'S E. YOU YOU HAVE
CUSTOMER SERVICE CALLS AND TIMES
AND WAIT TIMES CORRECT --
FINE AS THE DATE DVDS.
TRYING TO GO AND SAY OKAY WE WE
WANT TO DO FIFTEEN MINUTES AND
FORTY FIVE MINUTE.
IN THIS IS THE STANDARD OF
CUSTOMER SERVICE.
BUT DE FIND A REMARKABLE THAT
WERE CALLING.
IT THEY WERE CALLING OUR OUR
FOLKS CUSTOMERS BECAUSE QUITE
FRANKLY THEY CAN'T TAKE THEIR
BUSINESS SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WITH CUSTOMER SERVICE TIME IT IS
A RESTAURANT.
WAS MULTIPLE HOURS PEOPLE GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE.
WITH DMV THEY THEY DON'T HAVE
ANOTHER CHOICE.
AND SO IT'S IS JUST PREPOSTEROUS
TO ME THAT THEY WERE CALLING ON
CUSTOMERS WHEN IT WHEN THEY'RE
MORE TRAFFIC MEAN.
NORMAL CELLS LIKE THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE SAID HOTEL CALIFORNIA
YOU CHECK IN BEACON NEVER LEAVE.
AND IN THIS IS GETTING A FIX.
SO WITH AS THESE MATRICES ARE
DONE AND AS WE COME BACK TO
THESE HEARINGS.
I DEFINITELY WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING THERE I WANT TO SEE
SOMETHING.
IN THE MANAGEMENT.
IN IN WHAT'S GOING TO BE DONE AT
THE MANAGER LEVELS IN THE
SUPERVISOR LEVELS BECAUSE WHEN
WE GET THE PHONE CALLS AND WE WE
HEAR ABOUT THE STORIES OF YOU
KNOW EMPLOYEES THAT HAVE BEEN
SLEEPING HALF.
THE TIME THEY'VE BEEN ON THE JOB.
IT IT REALLY MAKES YOU ASK
WHAT'S HAPPENING WITH THE
MANAGERS.
AND THE SUPERVISORS WERE THESE
PEOPLE ACTUALLY DOING. TO ENSURE.
THAT THESE WAIT TIMES ARE
HAPPENING [inaudible]
THIS WAY.
IN THERE'S GOTTA BE SOMETHING
CHANGED WITHIN THAT.
EXPRESSION WHEN HE HOOKED HIS
ARE ASKING FOR BLANK CHECKS.
THIS COOPER MISTER COOPER
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
ANY OTHER [inaudible]
QUESTIONS.
OKAY CAN WE GET OUT A MOTION A
SECOND TO APPROVE S. B..
AS AMENDMENT IT --
IT SIX TWO AS AMENDED.
YES MISTER COOPER.
IT WHAT WILL MY CONCERN IS IS ON
ITEM NUMBER.
TWENTY WITH THE BILL REFORM SO.
IT'S KIND IN THE CART BEFORE THE
HORSE OVER.
ALLOCATING FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS FOR PROGRAM THE DOESN'T
EXIST RIGHT NOW.
AND THAT'S REALLY MY BIG ISSUE
WITH THAT.
SO S. B. TEN IS AN APPROPRIATION
SOMEWHERE LAST YEAR A. B. FORTY
TWO WHICH THIS OPINION BILL.
DIED.
IN THE ASSEMBLY SO.
WYRICK ALLOCATING MONEY FOR
PROGRAM.
THAT DOESN'T EXIST IN MAY NOT
EXIST.
NUMBER ONE IN THE NUMBER TO THE
ONGOING NEARLY KOSTER TUNER
MILLION DOLLARS [inaudible]
AND OBVIOUSLY.
YOU GOT A LOT OF FOLKS THAT WERE
ORIGINAL SPONSORS AND PULLED OFF
THE BILL NOW POSE THE BILL ALSO.
WHY ARE WE PUTTING DOWN THIS
ROAD?
JOSH DUGGAR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
SO WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S ONGOING
DISCUSSIONS REGARDING BAIL
REFORM AND THIS ESTIMATE THAT'S
INCLUDED IN THE BUDGET BILL --
IS COMPLETELY DEPENDENT UPON
THOSE --
DISCUSSIONS --
IF A BILL DID PASS WE KNOW THAT
THERE WOULD BE SOME FORM OF
START UP COSTS AND WE THINK AT
THIS POINT THIS IS A A
REASONABLE ESTIMATE OF THE START
UP COST.
HOW OFTEN DO YOU DO THAT FOR
SIMILAR BILLS AND JUST?
NOT EVEN BILL BILLS BUT DO WE DO
THIS I MEAN THAT'S THIS IS
HIGHLY UNUSUAL CORRECT
[inaudible]
I SORRY I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
SPEAK TO HOW OFTEN WE HAVE DONE
ASSEMBLY SENATOR YOUR TIME WHICH
YOU'VE BEEN IN THE OFFICE.
I AM NOT SURE I COULD SPEAK TO
THAT AND I APOLOGIZE OFF THE TOP
MY HEAD WHETHER OR NOT.
WE DON'T FEEL RECALL OUR I MEAN
AND THAT'S THAT'S A LEGITIMATE
QUESTION.
LIKE I'VE BEEN HERE FOR YEARS
NOW I DON'T SEEM TO RECALL MAYBE
I'M WRONG THAT'S WHY I'M ASKING
YOU BECAUSE YOU ALWAYS SEE
WORKING AT OFFICE THAT YOU DO OF
NUMBER OF BUDGET BILLS.
SO IN YOUR EXPERIENCE.
IN HELL YOU BEEN THERE.
FOR I'VE BEEN WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE ABOUT FIVE
AND HALF YEARS.
SO IN FIVE AND A HALF YEARS HAVE
YOU SEEN THIS DONE FOR ANY OTHER
BILL. TO THE BEST YOUR
RECOLLECTION. TO THE BEST OF MY
RECOLLECTION ON MY ASSIGNMENT
AREA I AM NOT FAMILIAR WITH THAT
BUT THAT'S A SMALL PORTION OF
THE OVERALL STATE.
BUDGET.
SO I TAKE THAT AS YOU DON'T KNOW
THAT ARE.
THAT'S CORRECT I AND I'M NOT
AWARE I DO NOT KNOW WHETHER OR
NOT THIS IS DONE IN OTHER AREAS
OF THE BUDGET.
WHO HAVE BIG ISSUES WITH WITH
PATROL REFORM INCLUDING THE OPEN
PROTOCOLS RULES OF COURT
TRAINING ADMINISTRATOR?
MYSTERY OF ISSUES WE TALKED
ABOUT THIS AND ONE THING WHAT I
TALK ABOUT THIS --
AD NAUSEAM IS.
IN IN CALIFORNIA JUDGES SET THE
BILL SO THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES
IN EVERY TWO YEARS A PANEL OF
JUDGES IN THOSE COUNTY SET THE
BILL.
SO BILL.
IN THE FIFTY EIGHT COUNTIES IN
ONE COUNTY FOR THE CHARGER
RODRIGUEZ TWENTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS.
IT WAS ALWAYS A TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND DOLLARS ANOTHER COUNTY
AND ANYWHERE IN BETWEEN SO.
THAT AS A BIG ISSUE EVEN THE
CHIEF JUSTICE SPOKE ABOUT IT. TO
US AND FURTHERMORE IN A LOT OF
FOLKS JUST DON'T SHOW UP THE
FIELD TO APPEAR AND THAT'S
REALLY A BIG ISSUE.
WITH FOLKS NOT SHOWING UP YOUR
DOCTOR'S OFFICE DENNIS OFFICE TO
GIVE YOUR CARD HEY HERE'S YOUR
DATE YOUR PLAY A SHOW UP.
AWFUL STILL SHOW FOR COURT AS WE
HAVE YOU KNOW OUSTING WARRANTS
IN THE MILLIONS IN CALIFORNIA SO
IT IT'S JUST IT'S JUST PUZZLING
AT ITS HEAD SCRATCHING.
KNOW WHY WE'RE DOING THIS
BETTING ON THE COM IT MAY NOT
HAPPEN NOVICE LAST YEAR WITH THE
I SAID EARLIER WITH AB FORTY TWO
IT DID NOT HAPPEN.
SO HERE WE ARE PUTTING MONEY.
FOR AND THERE'S WE NEED MONEY
ELSEWHERE LA PROGRAMS ARE VERY
WORTHY THAT WE CAN BE A SETTING
MONEY ASIDE.
IF IT DID PASS THEM FOR THEIR
OTHER BILLS IN THIS PACKAGE.
THAT MAY PATH THAT NO HEAVY.
DOES DE ARE DESIGNED OR DO
WHATEVER FUNDING STREAM DOES
NEED A FUNDING STREAM SO.
I GUESS SAID THIS IS THIS IS B.
S..
FLOOD LBS WHAT IS IN HERE.
AND IT IS TO A CERTAIN WITH THE
SYSTEM THE BILL IT'S IS POLICY
WILL COME TO ASSEMBLY FOR WILL
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
IN THE NEXT TWELVE DAYS.
BUT BUT TO HAVE THIS BILL HERE I
MEAN.
TO AND YOU WONDER WHY WE WONDER
WHY WHEN THE PROBLEMS WE ARE OR
TRY TO FIX IT HAVE DIALOGUE WITH
THIS.
AND THAT'S WHY ON THE FLOOR WILL
HAVE DISCUSSION DISCUSS IT BUT
BUT THE MONEY HERE.
I CAN'T VOTE FOR THIS.
BUT ALL PERIOD.
AND AND IT IS THIS IS REALLY
RESUME THE WRONG WAY TO HELP MY
COLLEAGUES ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
THIS IS NOT HOW YOU DO BUSINESS.
THIS IS NOT YOU KNOW YOU DID YOU
HAVE LIVELY DEBATE ABOUT ISSUES.
AND ALSO THE MONEY ASIDE.
SO WHAT HAPPENS IF THE MONEY.
THE BILL DOESN'T PASS.
WHAT HAPPENS THAT DISNEY MONEY
CAN YOU ANSWER THAT QUESTION FOR
ME?
YES THEIR PROVISIONAL LANGUAGE
INCLUDING THE BUDGET --
ONLY ALLOWS FOR THE EXPENDITURE
PENDING THE PASSAGE OF PRE TRIAL
REFORM LEGISLATION SO THERE
WOULD BE NO ADDITIONAL
EXPENDITURE.
YEAH LEVEL FOR THIS [inaudible]
MISS MATH [inaudible]
SO THAT I DID TO MY COLLEAGUE'S
QUESTION SO SO AMERICAN NATION
AND AND YOU'RE TRYING TO GET A
YES OR NO OUT OF YOU.
ON ON TO IF YOU SEEN THIS BEFORE.
YOU SAID IN IN YOUR FIVE AND A
HALF YEARS YOU HAVEN'T SEEN THIS
IN YOUR BUDGET.
AREA IS THAT CORRECT.
I DON'T RECALL SEEING IT IN MY
BUDGET AREA HIGH.
IT MEDICALLY CANNOT SPEAK TO
OVER THE FIVE AND A HALF YEARS
WHETHER OR NOT THEY'RE
SPECIFICALLY HAS HAPPENED IN MY
HEART BUDGET SO WE'RE WE'RE
GONNA.
MAKE A MOVE. TO CHANGE.
TO TO TAKE TAX DOLLARS TO PUT IN
A SYSTEM FOR BELL.
THAT HASN'T PASSED THE
LEGISLATURE YET.
JUST TO HAVE IT THERE JUST IN
CASE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING YOU'VE NEVER
SEEN IN FIVE AND A HALF YEARS.
SO TO CLARIFY --
I'M NOT SURE THAT THE
CLARIFICATION WILL ALLEVIATE ALL
OF YOUR CONCERN BUT THIS IS A
NOT A GENERAL APPROPRIATION THIS
IS FROM THE TRIAL COURT TRUST
FUND AND THERE WAS A AT THIS
POINT NO --
INCREASE TO THE REVENUE IN THE
TRIAL COURT TRUST FUND ALTHOUGH
THE PROVISION DOES INDICATE WHAT
THAT --
THERE WOULD BE AN INTENT TO
PROVIDE ENERAL FUND IN THE
FUTURE YEAR IF --
THEM IF THE EXPENDITURE OCCURS
AND THE PASSAGE OF PRE TRIAL
FORM LEGISLATION OCCURS
[inaudible] NINE A YEAH YOU
WOULD THINK IN ENDING MOST MY
CONSTITUENTS WOULD THINK THAT
YOU WOULD PUT.
PASSED THE LEGISLATION AND THEN
AFTER WE PASS IT IN IT GOES IN
THE LONG.
AND AFTER THE GOVERNOR SIGNED IT
AND THEN AS WE COME BACK OUT OF
NEXT YEAR [inaudible]
IF.
THE THIS BILL REFORM WAS TO PASS.
AND AND I SAY THAT IS A BIG IF
[inaudible]
THEN.
WE WOULD LOOK AT IT IN THE
BUDGET THE FOLLOWING YEAR SO SO
WHY WOULD WE DO IT.
I MEAN YEAH I HONESTLY AB A VIEW
YOU'VE NEVER SEEN THIS ANYWHERE
ELSE.
SO WHY WOULD WE BE DOING IT HERE.
I THINK THE THE ISSUE IS THAT --
IT'S REASONABLE TO ASSUME THAT
IF THE LEGISLATION DOES PASS
THERE WOULD BE REASONABLE START
UP COSTS IN THE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FISCAL YEAR SO
THAT YOUR RECOMMENDATION THAT
THE LEGISLATOR OUGHT TO DO ALL
OF OUR FINANCIAL COMMITMENTS ON
A WHAT IF BASIS.
I'M NOT SURE THAT I COULD SPEAK.
TO HOW THE A BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO SHOW.
YOU THAT THIS IS A WHAT IF THIS
HAPPENS.
IN IN IF WE'RE STARTING TO
LEGISLATE BASED ON WHAT IF AND
COMMIT STATE BUDGETS TO WHAT IF.
IS IS THIS OF ANY IN THIS ISN'T
A STANDARD PRACTICE.
SO IT IS IS YOUR RECOMMENDATION
IS SOMEBODY FROM THE PART IN A
FINANCES IS HOW WE SHOULD BE
OPERATING.
ARE ON A WHAT IF BASIS.
MY RECOMMENDATION ON THE AND IN
THIS PARTICULAR CASE THAT THIS
IS A A REASONABLE ASSUMPTION --
THAT THERE WOULD BE TWO THOUSAND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN START UP COSTS
IF LEGISLATION PASS AND THE WAY
THAT THE LANGUAGES WRITTEN I
THINK THAT IT PROTECTS AGAINST
ANY UNNECESSARY EXPENDITURES IN
THE INTENT THAT LEGISLATION DOES
NOT PASS NO I THINK.
RUNNING A WHAT IF BUDGET IS NOT
US MORROW FOR THE STATE
[inaudible]
MISS MELINDA'S.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I I
THINK EVERYBODY'S FIGURED OUT
THAT THERE'S SOME GREAT
FRUSTRATION WITH THIS PARTICULAR
BILL FOR A VARIETY OF REASONS --
AND I WILL AGREE WITH MY
COLLEAGUE MISTER COOPER THAT IT
IS UNUSUAL.
THAT WE WOULD PUT THAT MONEY IN
PRIOR TO THE BILL BEING APPROVED
I DON'T KNOW THAT WE DONE THAT
BEFORE I'M SO IT IT DOES.
SORT OF HINT AT PERHAPS THERE
BEEN SOME DISCUSSIONS THAT THE
REST OF US HAVE NOT BEEN PRIVY
TO THAT'S REALLY NOT.
YOUR AREA TO WORRY ABOUT YOUR
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
AND I JUST.
WANT TO MAKE CLEAR THAT --
YOU KNOW THE FOLKS WHO COME UP
WITH THESE BILLS AND WORKERS IN
IT.
DID YOU HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH
THE MONEY THAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATED TO THE DMV AND SETTING
THAT AMOUNT [inaudible]
NOW RIGHT.
YOU JUST RUN THE NUMBERS IS THAT
CORRECT.
I THINK AS THE OTHER GENTLEMAN
WHO WAS IN CHARGE OF DMT.
SO BUT HE WAS ASKING THE
QUESTION WHAT ABOUT [inaudible]
DMV.
RIGHT NOW HE THAT THIS DRAMA WAS
GOING TARGET.
BOTH AREAS OKAY I'M SORRY
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
WHO DID YOU WANT TO ANSWER THAT
QUESTION?
I THOUGHT FOR SURE HE WAS
ANSWERING SOME QUESTIONS ABOUT
FINDINGS.
WE'RE JUST TO UNVEIL REFORM WITH
HIM.
I'M CIRCUITRY BE THE QUESTION I
JUST WANT EVERYONE TO BE CLEAR
ABOUT WHO IS.
WHO'S RESPONSIBLE FOR THE
NUMBERS THAT ARE PLACED IN THESE
BUDGET TRAILER BILLS DID DID YOU.
COME UP WITH THESE NUMBERS WERE
YOU.
DIRECTED TO PUT I MEAN BECAUSE I
JUST.
I'M TRYING TO HELP ME OUT HERE I
FEEL LIKE THERE'S A LITTLE BIT
OF MISPLACED FRUSTRATION IN
WHAT'S IN THIS BILL.
WELL I CAN --
I MEAN THE PART OF FINANCE WORKS
WITH DEPARTMENTS AND AND IN
COMING UP WITH NUMBERS --
BROADLY --
AT I UNDERSTOOD THIS QUESTION AS
WELL.
THE DMP COMPONENT IS THAT SO
TERMS OF THOSE NUMBERS THAT WE
WORK WITH DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES AND TO COME UP WITH --
YEAH I IDENTIFY WORKLOAD AND
THEY YOU KNOW THAT'S A PROCESS
TO GO THROUGH WITH US.
SAY YOU HELPED IN CRAFTING THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT WOULD BE
ALLOCATED FOR THE DMV.
WHO WELCOMES THIS A LICK THE
CURRENT PROVISIONS DON'T
ACTUALLY --
ALLOCATE FUNDING FOR THAT IN
TERMS OF THAT.
THE FUNDING THAT HAS ALREADY
BEEN APPROVED THAT'S ALREADY
CURRENTLY IN THE BUDGET.
YES WE WORKED WITH THE MV TO GO
THROUGH THEIR WORKLOAD
ASSUMPTIONS AND AND STAFFING
ASSUMPTIONS.
OKAY LET ME REPHRASE THIS.
BECAUSE NOW I'M FRUSTRATED.
REMOVING THE LIMITATION.
IT WAS TWENTY SIX MILLION.
THAT LIMITATION HAS NOW BEEN
REMIT.
DID THAT COME FROM YOU OR YOUR
PARTICULAR PART OF THE
DEPARTMENT WAS A PART OF YOUR
DECISION TO DECIDE THAT THERE
THIS GUY SHOULD BE THE LIMIT.
YOU KNOW.
TV WHEN.
SO SO I PERSONALLY DID NOT.
WHAT WAS THAT PART OF THAT
PARTICULAR DISCUSSION THAT
YIELDED THAT RESULTS?
I KNOW THAT THERE WERE NUMEROUS
DISCUSSIONS.
THAT --
SOMEONE YOU WORK WITH
[inaudible]
PERHAPS.
A PERSON OR TWO LET LET ME
ANSWER THE QUESTION.
WHILE KNOW ACTUALLY I MISTER
CHAIRMAN WITH ALL DUE RESPECT I
WOULD HEAR FROM HIM SURE.
SO NOT YOU BUT SOMEBODY YOU WORK
WITH SOMEBODY IN YOUR OFFICE
SOMEONE IN THEIR HELPS TO COME
UP WITH THIS [inaudible]
NUMBER.
INTERNET HELP OTHER THE
DEPARTMENT AND IT TERMS OF THE
TWENTY SIX MILLION DOLLARS AS
WELL IN TERMS OF GETTING RID OF
THE LIMITS.
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS THAT
OCCURRED IN.
IN THE CONTEXT OF OF MEETINGS
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF MOTOR
VEHICLES.
AND THAT CHAIRS OFFICE AND
OTHERS.
I RECEIVED THE IT'S A RECEIVE
THE UPDATED LANGUAGE YESTERDAY.
THAT WAS YOU KNOW THEY CAME OUT
OF THOSE DISCUSSIONS
[inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible] TO COOPER.
IT'S ALSO INTERESTING THAT
REDUCING COST A LAW DOESN'T
EXIST YET --
SO YOUR ESTIMATING THAT FOR THE
ONGOING COST WILL BE TWO MILLION
DOLLARS A YEAR CORRECT
[inaudible]
YEAH.
CORRECT IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THE
IMPLEMENTATION.
OF PRIO TRIAL REFORM LEGISLATION
COULD --
COSTS APPROXIMATELY TWO HUNDRED
MILLION DOLLARS ANNUALLY BECAUSE
I I'VE BEEN TOLD BY INDIVIDUALS
THAT SIGNIFICANTLY MORE THAN
THAT.
WITH ALL THE PARTS THAT GO INTO
THAT [inaudible]
SO.
BUT WOULD WOULD COME UP WITH THE
WITH THE FIFTEEN MILLION. ONE I
THINK THAT.
THE SIGNIFICANT MAGNITUDE OF THE
TWO HUNDRED MILLION IS ALSO.
AN INDICATION OF WHY WE THINK
THAT IT'S PRUDENT TO SET ASIDE
TO RESEMBLE --
START UP COSTS.
FOR A OF POTENTIAL CHANGE OF
THIS MAGNITUDE AND I'M SORRY
WHAT WAS THE LAST QUESTION.
NOTHING I JUST MIGHT MY
STATEMENT IS AYE AYE SILICON
VALLEY'S IF IF IF MISS LYDIA
[inaudible]
COMMITTEE.
ON THIS BLOWS MY PERSONAL
FEELINGS [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER.
QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
MISTER BILL.
UGH JUST TO COMMENT ON THE ON
THE ISSUE OF BAIL REFORM THAT
THIS IS A FAIRLY UNIQUE
SITUATION AND IT IN IN MY VIEW
AND NOT ONLY --
BECAUSE I HAVEN'T SEEN SOMETHING
LIKE THIS ALTHOUGH IT CERTAINLY
MAY HAVE BEEN IN THE BUDGET AND
I JUST HAVEN'T.
HAD NOTICEDIT BEFORE A A A
CONTINGENT --
TO AMOUNT OF MONEY BUT AYE IN IN
THIS CASE --
THIS IS A PRIORITY OF THAT CHIEF
JUSTICE OF THE SUPREME COURT.
OF IT'S A PRIORITY OF THE
GOVERNOR AND THAT'S PRIORITY OF
BOTH OF THE LEADERS OF OTHER --
OF THAT HOUSES OF THE
LEGISLATURE --
AND SO I THINK THAT TO HAVE --
PUTS US IN A SOMEWHAT DIFFERENT --
CATEGORY WE RARELY SEE ALL THREE
BRANCHES OF GOVERNMENT PUSHING --
FOR REFORM --
IN THE WAY.
IF IT'S A CHIU PRIORITY OR TALK
ABOUT WITH TWELVE DAYS LEFT AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY [inaudible]
THIS.
BODY THEY SIMPLY.
THE BILL WAS KILLED LAST YEAR
DID NOT PASS TO DO NOT GET
ENOUGH VOTES ON THAT SO.
ASSIST BEEN GOING O FOR A LONG
TIME AND THAT OUR CAUCUS WE'LL
TALK ABOUT THAT.
IN THE CHIEF JUST THINKING OLIVE
SOME ISSUES I BOUGHT UP THAT IT
NEVER BEEN ADDRESSED BY ANYBODY
AT ALL.
SO IRAN IT'S COUNTY JAIL. FOR
TWO YEARS.
I SO I'M ACT AND BE HAPPY TO
RESPOND THAT MUCH OF THE CHAIR
WILL JUST TO GET A JOB AS
COLLOQUY NUMBERS TO CALL I MISS
MAKING COMMENTS BUT SO I I DO
NOT KNOW WHAT I'M TALKING ABOUT.
AND LAW THESE ISSUES IT'S IT'S
IT'S A THIS A LOT OF MOVING
PARTS TO IT.
WE ALL WANT IT FIXED WILL WANT
CHANGES BUT WE HAVE TO HAVE A
THOUGHTFUL AND DELIBERATE
DISCUSSIONS.
AND UP TILL NOW THAT HAS NOT
OCCURRED AND THAT'S THE REASON
SO.
SO JUST TO CLARIFY IF YOU ARE
WOULD LIKE TO BE CALLED THAT
PLEASE WAIT FOR ACKNOWLEDGEMENT
SOME MISTER BLOOM AYE COMMUTERS.
DAN AT AS MY COLLEAGUE COULD --
HIMSELF JUST ACKNOWLEDGE THIS
BILL HAS A IN ONE FORM OR
ANOTHER --
BEEN A PRIORITY FOR AT LEAST TWO
LEGISLATIVE SESSIONS NOW THERE
HAS BEEN A LOT OF DISCUSSION
AROUND THIS ISSUE --
HOT ALBEIT I UNDERSTAND THAT
THERE IS DISAGREEMENT OVER --
OVER THE ISSUE [inaudible]
BOOKS.
I THINK IT'S MCCARTY THANK YOU
GET JUST SOME CLARIFYING POINTS
ON THIS FOR THE FOR THE BIG
PICTURE I SUPPORT THEY'LL REFORM
AND THERE'S FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS.
FOR THE QUITE SAFE THERE BUT FOR
THEM PRETRIAL.
WHAT'S THAT CLARIFICATION PRE
TRIAL REFORM.
I AM DOWN JUST A NOTE THAT.
THIS IS A DEBATE ON THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET WHICH WENT INTO EFFECT
JULY ONE SO IF THIS PASSES WERE.
THREE MAYBE FOUR YEARS OF THE
FISCAL YEAR.
SO IF THAT IF THE REFORM PASSES
IN THE FALL.
BE SIGNED INTO LAW IT WOULD BE
IMPLEMENTED OVER THE OUT YEARS
AND SO.
THAT THERE IS THE PROJECTED AS
YOU SET UP TO TWO HUNDRED
BILLION DOLLARS IS REALLY AN OUT
YEAR BUDGET DISCUSSION THIS JUST
PROVIDES.
PROP PRUDENT COSTS BUT IN THE
BUDGET ARE PRETTY RESOURCE IN
THE BUDGET TO ADDRESS COST FOR
THE FINAL THREE OR FOUR MONTHS
IF THAT MEASURE GETS APPROVED BY
THE LEGISLATURE AND SIGNED BY
THE GOVERNOR.
AND IF IT DOESN'T.
THERE IS A CATCH IS TO GO BACK
TO ESSENTIALLY ARE RESERVE SO I
THINK THAT --
IT'S NOT IRRESPONSIBLE AND IT
SETS UP IN A WAY THAT --
MAKE SURE OF THIS MEASURE IS DOT
PASSED BY THE STATE CALIFORNIA'S
YEAR THERE'S SOME OPPORTUNITY TO
DO IMPLEMENTATION FOR THE FINAL
THREE YEARS FINAL THREE MONTHS
OF THE FISCAL YEAR [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
BUT I DON'T.
MISTER FEAR HOLD ON TWITTER.
WE GOT PEOPLE CONNECT.
I MISTER RESEARCH.
THANK YOU I DON'T WANT TO STATE
THE OBVIOUS BUT THE FOR THE
RECORD I WILL SUPPORT THIS BILL
BUT I RESERVE THE RIGHT. TO
OPPOSE THE BILL REFORM BILL.
I THINK MISS MASUCCI
[inaudible]
MISTER COOPER.
THIS WAS LIKE JUST ANOTHER
QUESTION I MY HOUSE SINCE I'M.
M. BEEN HERE THAT LONG AS LONG
AS OTHERS.
THERE ARE OTHER POTENTIAL BILLS
WERE VOTING ON THAT HAVE ACOSTA
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH THEM.
AND WE'VE NOT PLANNED OUT FOR
THOSE BILLS.
MR FINANCE I DON'T KNOW YOUR
NAME IS THAT CORRECT.
AND ARE YOU CAN READ REPEAT THE
QUESTION THE OTHER THEIR THEIR
ELDERS TODAY THERE THE BILL'S
WILL BE VOTING ON IN THIS BUDGET
THAT HAVE POTENTIAL COST.
IS THAT TRUE.
I'M I'M NOT SURE THAT I COULD
SPEAK TO ALL THE THE BILLS BUT I
THINK THAT GENERALLY SPEAKING
THE BILLS THAT WOULD BE VOTED ON
INCLUDE THE COST TO IMPLEMENT
THE BILL'S.
JUDGE I DON'T JUST OCCUR FROM
THIS COOPER QUESTIONS NOT
TOTALLY.
NAM.
IT DOESN'T HER WHERE WE DO.
APPROPRIATE MONEY IN THE BUDGET
PROCESS FOUR CONTINGENT ACTION.
SO THIS IS NOT THE FIRST TIME IT
WON'T BE THE LAST TIME IT HAS
HAPPENED BEFORE.
IT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT WE DO
ALL THE TIME.
BUT USUALLY WITH IN THE BUDGET
THERE ARE INSTANCES.
WHERE WE DO ON [inaudible]
APPROPRIATE.
WITH THE UNDERSTANDING THAT
THERE MAY OR MAY NOT BE AN
ACTION TAKEN.
DURING THE NEXT FISCAL YEAR
CREEK UNDERSTAND THAT THAT IS.
NOT THE NORM MORE OFTEN IT IS
NOT DONE THAT WAY.
IS THAT WE SOMETIMES I GREW
THREATENS TO MISTER TING BUT NOT
ALL THE TIME [inaudible]
CORRECT OKAY THANK YOU
[inaudible]
OKAY -- I
WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT IS
THERE ANY PUBLIC IN SUPPORT OF
SB [inaudible]
IT'S EXTERNAL.
ANY PUBLIC OPPOSED TO S. B. IT'S
SIXTY COME FORWARD [inaudible]
DON'T START.
CHAIRMAN MY APOLOGIES IN SUPPORT
OF THE MEASURE IN PARTICULAR
THAT --
TWENTY THREE POINT FIVE MILLION
AND DRINKING WATER ALLOCATION
THAT WILL HELP.
NEED SOME CRITICAL NEED CENTER
THROUGHOUT OUR STATE TO PROVIDE
DRINKING WATER TO FAMILIES WHO
CURRENTLY DO NOT HAVE THEM.
WHEN I THINK YOUR STAFF AND THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE AND OF MISTER
BLOOM FOR HIS LEADERSHIP ON
BRINGING THAT TO REALITY THANK
YOU?
THEY GO BACK TO SUPPORT.
YES SUPPORT AND I'LL HANDLE THE
DENVER THE WIDENING GROUP
REPRESENTING THE COMMITTEE WATER
SIGNER ALSO YOUR SUPPORT OF THE
THREE TWENTY THREE MILLION
DOLLARS AND CLEAN WATER ACTION
WAS AND THEY WOULD ATTEND HERE
BUT ALSO ON AND COMMUNICATING
THEIR SUPPORT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
JULIETT CHRISTIANS MET THEM WITH
THE WATER FOUNDATION WHERE A
PHILANTHROPIC ORGANIZATION A
PUBLIC CHARITY.
AND I JUST WANTED --
TO BE IN SUPPORT OF THE THREE
MILLION DOLLARS GOING INTO A
NEEDS ASSESSMENT I KNOW MANY OF
YOU.
ARE AWARE OF THE FACT THERE'S
NEARLY MILLION CALIFORNIANS THAT
DON'T HAVE ACCESS TO SAFE
DRINKING WATER TODAY.
AND ARE WORKING ON A SOLUTION TO
THAT PROBLEM.
THE STATE WATER BOARD HAS FOUND
THAT THERE ARE OVER THREE
HUNDRED PUBLIC WATER SYSTEMS AT
LEAST IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN THAT
ARE PROVIDING SAFE DRINKING
WATER.
BUT THAT DOESN'T TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT OVER TWO MILLION
CALIFORNIANS THAT ARE RELIANT ON
DOMESTIC WELLS AND SMALL SYSTEMS
SO THIS KIND OF NEEDS ASSESSMENT
IS CRITICAL FOR US TO UNDERSTAND.
WHERE THE NEED IS AND HOW MUCH
IT WILL [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
ANY ADDITIONAL SPEAKERS IN
SUPPORT.
OPPONENTS OF SB IT'S SIX TO ANY
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NONE COME ABOUT TO
COMMITTEE CAN I GET A MOTION --
TO APPROVED THE BILL WITH
AMENDMENTS.
TAKE A SECOND.
MA'AM SECTOR CRITICAL ROLE PLAYS
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM MY BRO [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
COME HERE I TRAVIS.
CHáVEZ NO CHIU CHOI NOT CHOI NO
COOPER.
COOPER NOT VOTING FONG.
FONG BUILD HARPER.
HARPER NO JONES SAWYER AYE JONES
SAWYER AYE COLOR.
COLOR COLOR I'D LACKEY NO LACKEY
NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ.
LET US KNOW MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
RADIUS.
REYES AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE [inaudible]
VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD.
ICE ELEVEN KNOWS NINE ONE NOT
VOTING [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
AND LET'S MOVE ON THAT SP EIGHT
SEVEN FOR OUR AUGUST EDUCATION
CLEAN A BILL.
THE BILL'S ON CALL RIGHT
.%
FEEL FREE NOT TO GIVE A TALK
.
IF YOU WOULD BE A WINNER S.
BREGUET.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIRMAN
RESIGNED JUST OFTEN DEPARTMENT
FINANCE --
WAS SOME BRIEF COMMENTS ON SP.
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR THIS BILL
APPROPRIATES --
TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS OF
PROPOSITION NINETY GENERAL FUND
FOR THE LOCAL CONTROL
ACCOUNTABILITY PLAN REDESIGN.
AS NUMBER OTHER COMPONENTS TO IT
IT --
PROVIDES AND JUST MEANT FOR THE
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE PROFESSIONAL
DEVELOPMENT BLOCK GRANT PROGRAM
BASICALLY IT WAS A FIFTY MILLION
DOLLAR PROGRAM IT TAKES FIVE
MILLION THAT. FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGE STAFF OF THE FIVE WOULD
GO TOWARDS THOSE EMPLOYEES IN
FORTY FIVE TOWARDS K..
TWELVE ALSO EXTENDS THE SCHOOL
BUS SAFETY ALERT SYSTEM
REQUIREMENTS THAT OUR EXISTENCE
PROVIDES AN ADDITIONAL AMOUNT OF
TIME FOR SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
COMPLY WITH THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THAT PROGRAM --
THERE ARE A NUMBER OF OTHER
TECHNICAL ADJUSTMENTS CONTAINED
IN THIS MEASURE --
IT EXTENDS LIQUIDATION REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE LOCAL
SOLUTIONS GRANT PROGRAM EXTENDED
IT FROM THREE TO FIVE YEARS --
FOR THAT FIFTY MILLION DOLLAR
PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES RESOURCES
FOR INCREASED SPECIAL EDUCATION
TEACHERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE ARE NUMBER OTHER TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS IN THE MEASURE BUT
IN ADDITION TO WHAT'S BEFORE YOU.
THERE ARE SOME COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS THAT WE'RE HERE TO
DISCUSS TODAY --
THERE ARE SOME TECHNICAL PIECES --
IS PART OF THAT THERE'S A AFTER
SCHOOL KIDS CODING ADJUSTMENT IN
THEIR THEIR SOME TECHNICAL
ADJUSTMENTS TO THE CLASSIFIED
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES PROGRAMS. TWO
OF THEM --
COMMUNITY COLLEGES FUNDING
FORMULA OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
ADJUSTMENTS AND THEN PERHAPS THE
LARGEST IS A A TACTICAL I'M
SORRY A COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS.
TO INCORPORATE A STATE
RECEIVERSHIP --
PROPOSAL THAT'S BEFORE YOU.
THAT HAS A COUPLE COMPONENTS TO
IT -- THE
FIRST COMPONENT IS A FISCAL
DISTRESS PIECE.
THIS PIECE OF JUST HOW WE WORK
WITH DISTRICTS IN FISCAL
DISTRESS WHEN THOSE SITUATIONS
ARISE.
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE SECOND COMPONENT IS IS A
PIECE THAT HAS FOR SPECIFIC
DISTRICTS.
THAT ARE IN FISCAL DISTRESS IN
STATE RIGHT NOW SPECIFICALLY FOR
INGLEWOOD UNIFIED IN OAKLAND
UNIFIED --
WITHOUT AS A WAY OF OVERVIEW I'D
BE HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY THINK OF A SPELL ARE
COMBATANT.
MR MEDINA HAS A QUESTION.
COULD YOU COULD YOU ELABORATE A
LITTLE BIT ON THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE --
THE NEW FUNDING FORMULA
[inaudible]
PLEASE.
YES WELL I'M THINKING CURRENTLY
BEING JOINED BY ONE OF MY ABLE
COLLEAGUES TO TALK WITH YOU MORE
ABOUT THAT.
YES CHRIS FERGUSON WHAT THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE WOULD BE
COMPRISED OF TWELVE MEMBERS UP
FOR FROM THE RAP FOR APPOINTED
BY THE ASSEMBLY FOR APPOINTED BY
THE SENATE AND FOUR BY THE
ADMINISTRATION THE COMMITTEE
WHAT SPECIFICALLY LOOK AT A
CERTAIN ACTION OR CERTAIN
COMPONENTS ON IN.
PARTICULAR WOULD BE LOOKING AT
UP FIRST GENERATION METRICS IT
WOULD BE LOOKING AT HOW WE
DEFINE LOW INCOME STATUS FOR
PURPOSES FORMULA.
IT WOULD BE LOOKING AT OVER
SESSION SCENARIO AS WELL AS
LOOKING AT THE INCORPORATION OF
A DOT.
NONCREDIT A DIVE FULL TIME
EQUIVALENT STUDENTS AS WELL AS
INSTRUCTIONAL SERVICE AGREEMENT
SO THAT THE COMMITTEE HAD SOME
WORK BEFORE IT.
ON BUT WE'RE CONFIDENT THAT THE
COMMITTEE WILL --
BRING FORWARD RECOMMENDATIONS
SURE AND THE ADMINISTRATION TO
CONSIDER.
AND THERE'S A BUDGET ALLOCATION
FOR THE COMMITTEE.
THERE IS NOT A SPECIFIC BUDGET
ALLOCATION FOR THE COMMITTEE THE
EXPECTATION IS THAT --
THE STAFFING FOR THE COMMITTEE
WOULD BE SUPPORTED BY THE YOU OF
FROM A FUNDING PERSPECTIVE BY
THE CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU NEED THE QUESTIONS
FROM THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY WILL GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC.
A START.
MISTER O'DONNELL MISTER --
ORNATE SOME FOUR CORRECT.
S. ARE.
GOING TO SHERMAN RESTLESS RIGHT
OUT -- JUST
A COUPLE QUESTIONS ABOUT THIS
UNITS LOOK AT THIS DOCUMENT
THERE'S A LOT OF POLICY IN HERE.
THERE REALLY SHOULD HAVE GONE
THROUGH THE POLICY COMMITTEE.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE.
IN I DESERVED MY COLLEAGUES TO
DO AS WE GO FORWARD WE NEED TO
THINK ABOUT THAT AS A BODY
BECAUSE WHY HAVE US WHY HAVE A
COMMITTEE PROCESS.
WHY HAVE POLICY COMMITTEES OF
WE'RE JUST GONNA DO EVERYTHING
IN THE BUDGET --
SO THAT THAT THAT'S SOMETHING
OUR BODY NEEDS TO TALK ABOUT --
WITH REGARD --
TO THE L. CAPPIES I THINK IT'S
GOOD THAT WERE STRENGTHENING THE
EL CAP DAY BE.
GIVEN MORE DEFINITION. TWO THE
ALL CAPS HAVING THEM POSTED ON
WEBSITES IS GOOD.
SO MY QUESTION IS WHY WOULD A
COUNTY OFFICE HAVE TO POSTED IN
EL CAP WHY WOULD A SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAVE TO POST IN NOW EL
CAP ON THEIR WEBSITE WHICH I
THINK IS A GOOD THING.
AND WHY WOULD NOT A CHARTER.
SPECIFICALLY LEAVES OUT CHARTERS
AND OTHER CONVERSATIONS ABOUT
PUTTING THE MEN AND I LIKE TO
KNOW WHY THEY ARE INCLUDING.
THIS IS GONNA COME BACK.
THIS IS SEVEN BEEN NAVY BUT IT'S
STRENGTHENS A CHARTER FOR PEOPLE
TO KNOW WHAT THE GOALS AND
MISSION ARE.
MAYBE YOU CAN HELP ME ON JUST GO
HOMES DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE
UNDERLING WHICH THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU THAT REQUIRES IT TO
BE ON THE HOME PAGE --
AND PROMINENTLY DISPLAYED SCHOOL
DISTRICTS ARE ALREADY REQUIRED
TO AND CHAOS EDUCATION ARE YOU
REQUIRED TO MAKE THEIR HOW CAPS
PUBLICLY AVAILABLE.
AND THAT IS NOT CURRENTLY THE
QUITE THE REQUIREMENT FOR
CHARTER SCHOOLS SO THE LANGUAGE
THAT YOU'RE SEEING IS TO
STRENGTHEN THE LANGUAGE THAT'S
ALREADY IN PLACE. FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN CHAOS IS OF
EDUCATION GREG THAT WAS MY
QUESTION THE QUESTION IS WHY ARE
CHARTERS INCLUDING.
SO.
WITH THE LANGUAGE THAT YOU SEE
BEFORE YOU AND THAT WASN'T PART
OF OUR DISCUSSION WE WERE.
HAVING A WHAT MIGHT ASSUME IT
WAS PART OF THE DISCUSSION SO
WHY WERE THEY SO THE THE
DISCUSSION WHAT THAT WE HAD WAS
ABOUT HOW DO WE MAKE.
AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT ALL CAPS --
MORE ACCESSIBLE FOR PARENTS AND
THE COMMUNITY MEMBERS --
WE DID NOT DISCUSS THEM MAKING
CHARTER SCHOOLS OKAY MARK MYERS
AND THERE WAS DISCUSSION AS AS
TO WHETHER NOT CHARTER SHOULD BE
PUT IN I JUST.
I MEAN YOU GOTTA TREAT THESE
INSTITUTIONS EQUALITY AND THIS
CLEARLY IS ANOTHER EXAMPLE --
ONE HEY YOU DON'T HAVE TO DO IT
YOU HAVE TO DO AND IT'S CLEARLY
GOOD PUBLIC POLICY TO HAVE IT.
ON THE WEBSITE SO PARENTS CAN
ACCESS THAT INFORMATION IS
RATHER UNFORTUNATE THAT YOU
CHOSE TO LEAVE IT OUT.
AND I'M SURE IT'LL BE A POINT OF
DISCUSSION GOING TOWARD THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU.
I THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
OKAY LET'S GO THE MEMBERS PUBLIC
A SUPPORT.
I I'D CHECK PRINTER BUT THE
CAMPAIGN FOR CALLED OPPORTUNITY
WE'RE GENTLY SUPPORTIVE OF THE
LANGUAGE AROUND THE OVERSIGHT
COMMITTEE FOR THE FUNDING
FORMULA HOWEVER AND THERE'S NO
INCLUSION OF A STUDENT
REPRESENTATIVE IN THAT
CONVERSATION WE THINK THAT'LL BE
CRITICAL TO SUCCESSFUL
IMPLEMENTATION.
WE WOULD URGE FOR CONSIDERATION
OF LANGUAGE THERE AS WELL AS THE
LANGUAGE AND THE INTENT OF THE
LEGISLATURE THAT THAT COMMITTEE
REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND BE INCLUSIVE OF
BOTH INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
STAKEHOLDERS. TO THE COLLEGE
SYSTEM THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON JENNIFER WITH THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION --
I WANTED TO KNOW THAT WE IN
PARTICULAR ARE APPRECIATIVE OF
THE FUNDS AND THE SUPPORT THAT
ARE BEING PROVIDED FOR BOTH
INCLUDE WIND AND OAKLAND UNIFIED.
AYE WE ALSO WANTED TO KNOW THAT
WE ARE NEW TO OCT NEUTRON THE
LANGUAGE HAS BEEN UP PUT
TOGETHER THAT WE UNDERSTAND IS
GOING TO BE AMENDED INTO THE
MEASURE.
OKAY AFTERNOON SEPARATE OUT ALL
THE FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIAN COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WITH REGARDS THE PROPOSED
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE ON THEY A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING
FORMULA.
WE SANTA ANA LETTER WITH SOME
SUGGESTIONS FOR THE COMMITTEE
AND LOWER OFFICIALLY NEUTRAL.
ARE WILLING TO HELP OUT IN ANY
WAY WE CAN --
AND WE APPRECIATE THE
LEGISLATURE'S ATTENTION TO THE
GREETINGS CHAIR TANG AND MEMBERS
OF THE BUDGET COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS VALERIE GOOD I'M THE DEPUTY
CHIEF OF COMMUNICATIONS OF
PUBLIC AFFAIRS FOR OAKLAND
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT I'M
JOINED.
BY L NEW
CHIEF BUSINESS OFFICER MARCUS
BATTLE --
TODAY'S A THIRD DAY OF SCHOOL SO
WE'RE HERE REPRESENTING DOCTOR
DUH CHILODONTIDAE TREMELLA OUR
SUPERINTENDENT SHOW SUPPORT --
FOR THIS --
THE PROPOSAL REFLECTS THE
SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENT TOWARD
DISTRICT --
TO WORK WITH ALAMEDA COUNTY IN
THE STATE --
TO WORK TOGETHER.
SO THAT WE BECOME PHYSICALLY
STABLE SUSTAINABLE --
WE APPRECIATE THE STRUCTURE AND
THE PROPOSAL.
AS IT SET SPECIFIC BENCHMARKS
THAT WILL NEED TO MEET AND
REQUIRE --
THAT WE CONTINUE TO MAKE
DIFFICULT DECISIONS AND
ULTIMATELY ELIMINATE OUR
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT AND RIGHT
SIZE THE DISTRICT. FOR FOR SO
FOR THESE REASONS WE SUPPORT THE
LANGUAGE INCLUDED SP.
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR I'M AS PROPOSED
AND RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR
AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MICHELLE MCCANN
UNDERWOOD ON BEHALF OF THREE
MEMBERS OF THE OAKLAND UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD --
AS YOU CAN IMAGINE UP THE
LEGISLATIVE PROCESS SOMETIMES
MOVES MORE QUICKLY THAN A BOARD
CAN TAKE FORMAL ACTIONS SO I'M
HERE I REPRESENTING THE SUPPORT
OF BOARD PRESIDENT HANG.
MEMBERS LONDON AND ST I'M WHO
ARE THE MOST INVOLVED IN THE
CONVERSATIONS AROUND OAKLAND
UNIFIED HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
WE WANT TO EXPRESS OUR SUPPORT
FOR THE PROVISIONS FOR DISTRICTS
AND FISCAL DISTRESS --
AS MENTIONED BY MISS GOOD --
THERE'S DEFINITELY UNDERSTANDING
THAT DIFFICULT DECISIONS WILL
NEED TO BE MADE --
BY THE LEADERSHIP OF THE BOARD
AND WE ARE VERY HAPPY FOR THE
PARTNERSHIP THAT IS BEING
PROPOSED BY THE DISTRICT AND THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND FOR
THESE REASONS WE RESPECTFULLY
REQUEST YOUR AYE VOTE.
AND I HAVE LETTERS FROM THE
BOARD MEMBERS TO SUBMIT.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON VERY SNOBBY OF
THE ALAMEDA COUNTY
SUPERINTENDENT ACKERMANWROTE
SHE RECEIVED A PROPOSED
AMENDMENTS LAST NIGHT.
AFTER A CALL WITH THE OAKLAND
UNIFIED SUPERINTENDENT SHE OF
COURSE LIKE THE OPPORTUNITY
PROVIDES AND MEANINGFUL AND AND
PUT AND SHE WILL DO THAT IN THE
NEXT COUPLE DAYS YOU JUST HAVE
BEEN ABLE.
TO WE'RE ANALYZES COULD FAST
ENOUGH AND WILL SHARE THAT WITH
DEPARTMENT FINANCE AND SENATE.
MR CHAIRMAN --
MEMBERS BILL LUCY WITH THAT
VOICE --
WANTED TO SPEAK SPECIFICALLY TO
A FEW ISSUES ONE WAS ON THE
FISCAL TRANSPARENCY LANGUAGE.
DEALING WITH AL CAPP TEMPLATES
WHERE I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU
APPRECIATIVE TO THE CHAIR THE
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE CHAIR DR
WEBER ALSO FOR THE WORKING THE
STAFF IN MOVING THE NEEDLE.
ON INCREASING APPROVED SERVICES
AND MORE TRANSPARENCY WE WE DO
BELIEVE THERE IS MORE TO GO BUT
THIS.
THIS NEEDS TO BE DONE AND IT
NEEDS TO KEEP GOING FORWARD AND
NOT THINK THAT WE'VE HIT THE
PINNACLE OF SUCCESS IN.
TRANSPARENCY INCLUDING
INFORMATION FOR PARENTS UP TO
BEING ACTIVELY ENGAGED IN
HELPING TO TARGET RESOURCES
WHERE THEY'RE NEEDED MOST FOR
THE AND DEPARTED STUDENTS.
UP HAVING SAID THAT WE STRONGLY
RECOMMEND THAT YOU CONSIDER
FORMAL WORK GROUP FITS IN
STATUTE THE REPORTS AINLEY BACK
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
SO THAT THERE'S ACTUALLY COUNTY
BILLY TO THIS BODY IN YOUR
SUBCOMMITTEE PROCESS ON A
REGULAR BASIS TO ENSURE THAT
TRANSPARENCY IN STRENGTHENING
TRANSPARENCY ACTUALLY IS A
COMMITMENT BY THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONTINUE TO HAPPEN BECAUSE THIS.
THIS IS PROBABLY LESS THAN HALF
A CUP BUT WORTH DOING.
AND COMMENTING ON OTHER
PROPOSALS ARE THERE IN THIS THEY
WERE JUST DESCRIBED IS
AMENDMENTS I'D HAVE TO SAY I
JUST FOR THE RECORD I'VE BEEN
HERE LONGER THAN FIVE AND A HALF
YEARS I'VE BEEN HERE TWENTY NINE
YEARS STARTING OUT THE
DEPARTMENT FINANCING LETTER
DELEO.
NEVER ONCE IN A FISCAL THE THE
ISSUE OF TAKING OVER A WHOLE
DIFFERENT APPROACH TO FISCAL
DISTRESS BEEN HANDLED IN A
BUDGET COMMITTEE IN THIS KIND OF
A PROCESS WITH LITTLE PUBLIC
INPUT -- I
GUARANTEE YOU YOU CAN'T FIND A
SINGLE PIECE OF LEGISLATION IN
TWENTY NINE YEARS THAT YOU'VE
EVER DONE THIS NEEDS MORE
TRANSPARENCY EITHER IN THE
FISCAL POLICY DISCUSSION OF A
BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE.
OR IN THE POLICY COMMITTEE
ITSELF THANK YOU.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS BRIAN
REAVIS ON BEHALF OF THE
EDUCATION TRUST WEST WE FEEL
SIMILAR LEAD TO MR LUCIER AND MY
COLLEAGUES FROM AT VOICE --
WE URGE YOU TO AN ACT THE
PROVISIONS IN THIS BILL RELATED
TO TRANSPARENCY BUT WE WOULD ASK
OR WE WOULD URGE CAUTION AND WE
ASK THAT YOU NOT CONSIDER THIS --
KEYS CLOSE AND THINK THAT WE
ADDRESS ALL OF THE TRANSPARENCY
ISSUES THIS IS GOOD WORK A STEP
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION BUT WE
STILL HAVE SOME WORK TO DO
AROUND IDENTIFYING HOW MUCH THE
STATE IS SPENDING. TO INCREASE
AND IMPROVE SERVICES FRONT
DUPLICATED STUDENTS AND ALSO
DOCTOR WEBER IS BEEN OF MARBLES
CHAMPION AROUND THE ISSUE OF
SCHOOL SITE TRANSPARENCY WE
THINK THAT'S ANOTHER AREA.
THAT NEEDS SOME MORE WORK SO
THANK YOU FOR THE WORK AND WE
URGE APPROVAL BUT WE WE DO NEED
SOME KIND OF ON GOING PROCESS TO
CONTINUE IMPROVING TRANSPARENCY.
SOME ARE WITH THAT CALIFORNIA'S
GOING PLACES THAT STATION WE ARE
HERE TO SUPPORT EXPRESS THEIR
SUPPORT FOR THE FIVE MILLION
DOLLAR FOR CAMINO COLLEGE FOR
CLASSIFYING EMPLOYEE
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
AND FOR THE EXTENSION TO
RETROFIT SCHOOL BUSES --
WHICH OUT SAFETY OTHER SYSTEM WE
ALSO WOULD LIKE TO THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF FOR ALL THEIR
WORK ON THESE IMPORTANT ISSUES.
JERRY MEMBERS BRAD STRONG SENIOR
DIRECTOR EDUCATION AT CHILDREN
NOW I'M ACTIONS THAT WE ARE
SUPPORTIVE OF THE ACTIONS --
AND SERVICES SUMMARY CHART THE
INCREASED IMPROVE SUMMARY CHARTS
AND WE THINK THOSE ARE IMPORTANT
AND AND GOOD STEPS FORWARD AS
WELL AS THE THE ACCESSIBILITY
ONLINE -- WE
USE COULD STILL HAVE A SINCE THE
OF THE EQUITY COALITION
SUBMITTED A LETTER WITH OVER
TWENTY SIGNATURES OF
ORGANIZATIONS.
AND THAT WE HOPE YOU'LL CONSIDER
INCLUDING BEFORE ADOPTION
MEDICINALLY WE'VE BEEN TOLD THAT
THE THE REPORTING OF ACTUAL
EXPENDITURES FOR EACH LEN EACH
SCHOOL IS REQUIRED BY THE EVERY
STUDENTS SUCCEED ACT IS NOT
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THIS
CONVERSATION.
I'M CHILDREN NOW AND I AND I
KNOW OTHERS HAVE BELIEVE THAT
THIS IS CRITICALLY IMPORTANT FOR
COMMUNITIES TO BE ABLE TO
MONITOR AND THE EQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF RESOURCES WITHIN
A SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BUT IF THAT INFORMATION IS NOT
ACCESSIBLE EVEN IF IT IS
COLLECTED IN REPORTED SOMEWHERE
THAT IT'S NOT USEFUL.
OF FEDERAL LAW NO LONGER
PROVIDES FOR THE PROTECTIONS
ASSOCIATED WITH SUPPLEMENT NOT
SUPPLANT.
THROUGH THE ONEROUS ACCOUNTING
OF EXPENDITURES IN ROOM AND THAT
RESTRICT THE USE OF FUNDS
INSTEAD RATHER.
THAN ACCOUNTING FOR HOW THE FOR
THEIR SPENDING FUNDS DISTRICTS
WILL NOW FOCUS ON HOW THE
ALLOCATE.
STATE AND LOCAL RESOURCES --
ACCORDING TO EVERY STUDENTS AND
IT IS S. AS A REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS THAT ARE INTENDED
TO ENSURE THAT PARENTS AND
COMMUNITIES.
CAN -- MORE
CLOSELY MONITOR THE ALLOCATION
OF RESOURCES TO THE VARIOUS
SCHOOL SITES WITHIN THE DISTRICT.
AND WHAT WE DON'T KNOW IS WHAT
MONITORING WILL BE DONE IN
CALIFORNIA TO INSURE THAT SOCIO
ECONOMICALLY DISADVANTAGED
SCHOOLS ART BEING SHORT CHANGED
WITH RESPECT TO THE ALLOCATION
OF RESOURCES AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY.
HOW A CALIFORNIA ENSURE ACCESS
TO THE SUB SITE LEVEL
EXPENDITURES IN A MANNER THAT
ENABLES MEANINGFUL ENGAGEMENT
AND LOCAL SPENDING DECISIONS?
DOCTOR WEBER WEBER AUTHORED AB
TOUGH THIRTEEN TWENTY ONE LAST
YEAR TO HAVE THAT DISCUSSION BUT
IT WAS DEEMED PREMATURE.
THIS YEAR THE EQUITY COALITION
ELEVATED IN TERMS OF THE FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY CONVERSATIONS AND
HAVE BEEN ADVISED IT ISN'T
WITHIN THE PURVIEW OF THIS
WORKGROUP.
AND YET THE QUESTION OF USEFUL
ACCESS TO THIS DATA IS STILL
UNRESOLVED WE HOPE THE COMMITTEE
WILL CONTINUE TO INCORPORATE
TECHNICAL OCEAN LETTERS.
AND RECOMMENDATIONS WE ASK THAT
THE LEGISLATURE.
ACTUAL EXPENDITURES FOR
REPORTING FOR EACH LEN EACH
SCHOOL SITE AND DO GREATLY
APPRECIATE THIS COMMITTEE'S WORK.
AND THE WORK GROUP ITSELF THANK.
GOOD AFTERNOON TARA LOIS
EXECUTOR ACTOR OF TEACH PLUS AND
I ONE ASSOCIATE MY COMMENTS WITH
MY COLLEAGUES FROM THE LCF
EQUITY COALITION THANK YOU.
WE OUT WE APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS TOWARD FISCAL
TRANSPARENCY WITH US EL CAP
ADDITION --
BUT THE LIKE HER COLLEAGUES
DON'T BELIEVE IT TAKES US FAR
ENOUGH TO REALLY BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS OF HOW MUCH
AND HOW MONEY IS ACTUALLY BEING
SPENT IT INCREASE ARE PROOF
SERVICES FOR THE STUDENTS WAS
INTENDED TRUMP.
TOOK TO ADDRESS AND WE HOPE THAT
YOU CAN LOOK AT SOME OF THOSE
SPECIFIC RECOMMENDATIONS ON IN
THAT LETTER AND THINK ABOUT THAT
THE CONVERSATION MOVING FORWARD --
WE WOULD ALSO REITERATE THE
RECOMMENDATION OF EXPRESS MY
ADVICE FOR FOR STATUTORILY
REQUIRED A STAKEHOLDER GROUP TO
REVISIT THIS ISSUE --
BUT WITH THE LEGISLATURE BECAUSE
IF WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT THE
LOCAL PLANNING PROCESS BILLION
REFLECTING THE NEEDS AND
INTERESTS OF ALL LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS FAMILIES STUDENTS
EDUCATORS IN THE COMMUNITY.
THAT THIS TOOL IS IT NEEDS TO BE
[inaudible]
BETTER.
AND BETTER INTEGRATED INTO ALL
OF OUR SCHOOL IMPROVEMENTS UMP.
GOOD AFTERNOON US WHISKEY AND
WITH PUBLIC ADVOCATES --
WE SUPPORT THE BILL ARE AS IT
RELATES TO THE EL CAP TEMPLATE
IMPROVEMENTS --
BECAUSE THERE ARE SOME
BUT A SOME OF MY OUR ALLIES IN
THE EQUITY COALITION HAVE SAID
THIS DOES NOT ANSWER THE
QUESTIONS THAT ARE YOU HAVE BEEN
OF SEEKING FOR YEARS.
OR OR OR THAT WE HAVE BEEN
SEEKING FOR YEARS.
PACIFIC WAY HOW MUCH THE STATE
IS PROVIDING TO INCREASE AND
IMPROVE SERVICES FOR ON
DUPLICATED STUDENTS AND HOW MUCH
OF LCF OF FUNDING IS BEING USED
FOR THOSE PURPOSES.
AT THE LOCAL LEVEL AND SCHOOL
SITES -- WE
AGREE THAT THERE SHOULD BE --
SOME STAKEHOLDER PROCESS MOVING
FORWARD.
OF AND FOR FOR COMMUNITY
ORGANIZATIONS PARENTS AND LOCAL
STAKEHOLDERS THAT HAVE BEEN
FAITHFULLY ENDING GOOD FAITH
WORKING. TO MAKE THE EL CAP
PROCESS WORK THIS IS GONNA BE
REALLY CHALLENGING FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY'VE BEEN ABLE TO GET
THEIR DISTRICTS TO BE MORE
TRANSPARENT THAN WHAT.
THIS BASELINE LANGUAGE REQUIRES
SO WE REALLY WANT TO ENCOURAGE
YOU TO THINK ABOUT USING TERMS
LIKE AT A MINIMUM.
OR SO THAT DISTRICTS DON'T FEEL
LIKE THEY HAVE TO PULL BACK I
ALSO WANT --
TO JOINED OF THE COMMENTS OF OF
OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY WITH REGARD TO THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE FUNDING
FORMULA.
AND THE OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE
PLEASE PLEASE INCLUDE STUDENTS
THANKYOU.
PARA PREMARKET THE CHARTER
SCHOOLS DEVELOPMENT CENTER OF WE
ARE IN SUPPORT OF THE CHANGES TO
THE EL CAP TEMPLATE IN
APPRECIATE THE SENSITIVITY TO
THE UNIQUE NEEDS OF CHARTER
SCHOOLS AND THE AMENDMENTS.
WE DO HAVE SOME VERY GRAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE LAST MINUTE.
INSERTION OF PROVISIONS
REGARDING SURPLUS PROPERTY AND
THAT FINANCIALLY DISTRESSED
SCHOOL DISTRICTS AND DO BELIEVE
THAT THAT SHOULD BE ADDRESSED
OUTSIDE OF THE CONTEXT OF A
BUDGET CLEAN UP BILL THANK YOU.
IF JOHN WINGER ON THE OFF THE
CALIFORNIA CHARTER SCHOOLS
ASSOCIATION --
INTEREST THE TIME I JUST
ASSOCIATE R. COMETS WITH CHARTER
DEVELOPMENT CENTER ON THE EL CAP
IN APPRECIATE THE AMENDMENTS TO
IT -- WE DO
ALSO HAVE --
CONCERNS ON THE SURPLUS PROPERTY
PIECE THAT WE SHARED OUR
COMMENTS AND FEEDBACK WITH YOUR
STAFF AND LOOK FORWARD TO
CONTINUING TO ENGAGE WITH --
BOTH YOU AND THE DEPARTMENT ON
IT THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS PAMELA GIVES
REPRESENTING THE LOS ANGELES
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION FIRST
OF ALL I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR CONSIDERING THE
AMENDMENTS TO SB.
EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR AND THE
FISCAL OVERSIGHT OF SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN DISTRESS AS MANY OF
YOU KNOW LAY CHO HAS SUPPORTED
LEGISLATION PERTAINING TO THE
SURPLUS PROPERTY.
AND THE ABILITY TO HELP RESOLVE
THE ISSUES OF SCHOOL DISTRICTS
IN DISTRESS AND WE CONTINUE TO
BE INTERESTED IN THIS ISSUE.
SO ALTHOUGH I WE ARE STILL
REVIEWING THE AMENDMENTS WOULD
LIKE TO WORK WITH THE DEPARTMENT
FINANCING ADMINISTRATION AND
OTHER STAKEHOLDERS TO SEE THIS
ISSUE MOVE FORWARD --
PREVIOUS TO ADOPTION SO THANK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON MARTHA SIRINGO
CITY S. AND I'M REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION FOR
BILINGUAL EDUCATION AND
CALIFORNIANS TOGETHER.
I WOULD LIKE TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF
WITH CONCERN I MEAN WITH THEA.
COMMENTS MADE THE STATEMENTS
MADE BY THE RIGHT VOICE FROM
THIS I TRUST WEST AND FROM
PUBLIC ADVOCATES WE SUPPORT THE
BILL MOVING FORWARD.
AYE AND WE APPRECIATE THE
PROGRESS IBM MADE WITH REGARDS
TO FISCAL TRANSPARENCY BUT
BELIEVE THAT THERE STILL
ADDITIONAL WORK NEEDED. TO BE
ABLE TO DETERMINE HOW MUCH MONEY
HAS BEEN ALLOCATED FOR OUR A
DUPLICATED PUPILS AND WHERE THAT
INVESTMENT HAS INDEED HELP
NARROW THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP THAT
WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
ADDITIONALLY I DO SUPPORT THE
CONSIDERATION OF THE WORK GROUP
TO BE ABLE TO A LOOK AT THESE
ISSUES FURTHER.
BUT IN ADDITION A FIRE
APPRECIATE AND SUPPORT THE
INCLUSION OF FIVE TWO OH SIX
FOUR HE THAT'S IN THE BILL.
WHICH REQUIRES THAT THERE BE
SPECIFIC INSTRUCTIONS MADE BY
THE STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION TO
THE ELEAZAR WITH REGARDS TO
INCLUDING ACTIONS IN THEIR EL
CAP SPECIFIC TO ENGLISH LEARNERS
BECAUSE THAT HAS BEEN A PROBLEM.
IN THE PAST WHEN WE'VE REVIEWED.
ALL OVER I DON'T KNOW TWENTY
FOUR AL CAPS OVER THE PAST FOUR
YEARS THAT HAS BEEN A
SIGNIFICANT PROBLEM AND
HOPEFULLY.
THIS WILL ADDRESS SOME OF THE
BECAUSE SOME OF THOSE PROBLEMS.
ARE THERE IS A CONCERN OF THE
BILL IS PROPOSING TO REPEAL.
A SECTION SIX OR EIGHT ONE ZERO
OUR I JUST A LOOKED AT THAT
TODAY I DON'T KNOW WHAT OUR
POSITION WOULD BE ON THAT
SPECIFIC REPEAL BUT SHOULD HAVE
AN ANSWER BY THE END OF THE DAY
TODAY.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY ADDITIONAL PUBLIC
COMMENT.
PUBLIC COMMENT IN OPPOSITION.
OKAY SAYING NONE LIKE.
TO DOCTOR WEBER.
YES I AM I WANT TO THANK ALSO
THE STAFF AND WHO WORK VERY HARD
ON THIS ISSUE --
THEY'VE BEEN WORKING OVER THE
BREAK AND ALL ALONG TO REALLY
TRY TO COME UP WITH SOMETHING
THAT WOULD DOWN.
IMPROVE OUR EL CAP AND AND
CREATE SOME TRANSPARENCY AROUND
THE ISSUE OF THE FUNDING AND
WHETHER OR NOT WE'RE REALLY.
GETTING THE MONEY TO THE KIDS
WHO WE SAY WE WERE GOING TO GIVE
IT TO FOUR YEARS AGO FIVE YEARS
AGO.
AND WHETHER THAT WE'VE ACHIEVED
THAT --
WE'RE A LONG WAY FROM ACTUALLY
PRODUCING A DOCUMENT THAT MAKES
SENSE TO PARENTS AND THAT WAS
THE CHARGE AND MANY WAYS TELLING
APPROVAL CAP.
IMPROVE THE STRUCTURE BUT MORE
IMPORTANTLY TO MAKE IT AVAILABLE
FOR PARENTS TO KNOW AND TO BE
ABLE TO DO SOME DISCUSSION IN
COMPARISON ABOUT WHERE MONEY IS
GOING WITHIN THAT IS BEING PUT
IN THE RIGHT DIRECTION.
WHETHER NOT THAT THINGS THAT
NEED TO BE TWEAKED IN AND AND
AND AND CHAINS IN ORDER TO BE
MORE EFFECTIVE.
SO WE'RE LONG WAY FROM THAT AND
I REALLY WANT TO THANK ALL THOSE
WHO WORK BECAUSE SOME OF YOU
HAVE PUT IN.
SOME LONG HOURS FOR THE LAST.
FIVE WHEN WE WERE SURE THAT
THERE WOULD BE TRANSPARENCY WITH
EL CAP WITH LC A FAST AND WE
DIDN'T GET IT THEN AND WAS STILL
STRUGGLING WITH THAT TODAY.
AND WE'VE BEEN TOLD TO DELAY
DELAY DELAY FOR FOUR YEARS NOW
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD TO WE NEED TO
CREATE SOME SENSE OF
TRANSPARENCY AND WE STILL HAVE
NOT.
WAS SITTING AND I HAVE WORKED ON
THIS FOR FIVE YEARS I THINK
SINCE EL CARE SINCE WE DID LCF
AB.
AND IT CAN BE VERY FRUSTRATING --
TO THOSE OF US AS I LOOK AT WHAT
WE PRODUCED AFTER ALL THESE
YEARS.
I STILL DON'T BELIEVE BACK AND
HANDED TO US SOME OF MY MOST
ACTIVE PARENTS IN MY DISTRICT
AND SAY.
ARE WE DOING A GOOD JOB IS THIS
MORE THE MONEY SHOULD BE GOING
AYE WE REALLY FOCUSING ON THE
KIDS OF MEAT AS WE SAID WE WOULD
DO.
A FIVE YEARS AGO WHEN I CAME
INTO THIS HOUSE SO --
I WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
CONTINUE TO WORK OF THESE ARE
SOME REAL DEDICATED INDIVIDUALS
WHO'VE WORKED.
ALL ON THIS ISSUE FROM ALL THE
DIFFERENT AGENCIES AS WELL AS
OUR STAFF --
WE WILL NOT GIVE UP.
WE WILL FIGURE THIS OUT MOST OF
YOU KNOW I IF LORD WILLING AND
THE CREEK DON'T RISE I HAVE SIX
MORE YEARS.
AND AND WE WILL ACCOMPLISH THIS
WE WILL FIGURE OUT WHERE THE
MONEY GOES AND EVEN IF IT
DOESN'T GO IN THE DIRECTION WE
WANTED TO GO WE NEED TO KNOW
WHERE HE IS.
AND WHETHER NOT ACCOMPLISHING
THE GOAL AND HOW MUCH PROGRESS
WE ARE MAKING A NOT MAKING ON
CLOSING THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP --
SO I I'M COMMITTED THIS I WANT
TO THANK THOSE WHO ALSO WORKED
ON THE THREE HUNDRED MILLION FOR
THE KIDS WILL LEFT BEHIND.
AND THE WORK THAT'S BEEN DONE IN
TERMS OF IMPROVING THE LANGUAGE
IN THE TESTING FOR THAT TO
ACCOMPLISH.
OF WHAT WE NEED TO ACCOMPLISH
BUT IT'S BEEN A IT'S BEEN A
JOURNEY AND I'M NOT PLEASE IN
THEY'RE NOT PLEASE BUT WE KNOW
WAS SLOWLY MAKING THESE BABY
STEPS.
BUT WE'VE GOT TO GET FAST AND
WE'VE GOT TO GET BETTER BECAUSE
EVERY DAY THAT WE DELAY AND
WE'RE NOT SURE WHERE THE MONEY
GOES WE HAVE CHILDREN'S LIVES
WHO IN OUR HANDS.
THAT NOT BEING ADEQUATELY SIR
THANK YOU.
I BELIEVE THE BILL.
THANK YOU BYE MISTRUST.
I GOTTA MAKE A FEW COMMENTS ON
THIS I'VE BEEN INVOLVED THIS
ALSO FOR SIX YEARS --
THERE ARE LOT OF THINGS IN HERE
THAT DEAL WITH POLICY NOW LIKE
TO REFER LIKE ON SOME OF THE
COMMENTS MADE EARLIER.
THIS IS THE BUDGET COMMITTEE AND
I THINK IT WOULD PROBABLY HAVE
BEST A BEEN THERE --
TO LOOK AT SOME OF THESE MOB
POLICY ISSUES.
THAT BEING SAID [inaudible]
THE TRANSPARENT SHE'S BEEN ONE
OF THE BIGGEST ISSUE WE LOOKED
AT MAKE YOU DOUBT CAP A RELEVANT --
DEALING WITH THE DASHBOARD.
PUT IT ONLINE --
BUT ONE OF THE MISTAKES I THINK
WE MAKE [inaudible]
SACRAMENTO.
IN THE ASSEMBLY.
IS THAT WE FEEL LIKE WE HAVE THE
OWNERSHIP OF EVERYTHING IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEM IF YOU LOOK AT LOCAL
CONTROL FUNDING AND HELP CAP IT
WAS TO EMPOWER.
THE LOCAL SCHOOL DISTRICTS TO
TAKE OWNERSHIP OF THEIR OWN
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
I'VE TAKEN A GREAT --
LOT OF TIME IN MY OWN DISTRICT
TO LOOK AT HOW MY SCHOOL
DISTRICTS HAVE DEALT WITH THIS
[inaudible]
AND AND TO SUMMER SCHOOL
DISTRICTS RIGHT NEXT TO EACH
OTHER [inaudible]
SAME DEMOGRAPHICS --
ONE HAS DONE A GREAT JOB WITH
LOCAL OR DRAW FUNNY THAT HELLCAT
BECAUSE THEY EMPOWERED THEIR
COMMUNITIES AND THEY WOULDN'T OF
THE CHURCHES IN THE COMMUNITY
GROUPS.
AND THE PGA IS AND IF YOU LOOK
AT THEIR PRODUCT.
IN LOOK AT THE RESULTS GIVEN TO
THOSE STUDENTS --
THE FIRST THREE GREAT FIRST
SECOND THIRD YEAR OUTPERFORMING
SOME OF THE HIGHEST PER.
ACADEMICS BECAUSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN MY DISTRICT.
RIGHT NEXT DOOR ANOTHER ONE IS
FAILING.
BUT THEY HAVE.
AND THAT'S SCHOOL THEY'RE SICK
OF MY OPINION THEY HAVE NOT
ENGAGE A COMMUNITY THEY TOOK ON
THE OWNERSHIP TO THEM SOLVE TO
SCHOOL BOARD.
AND THE ADMINISTRATORS BECAUSE
THEY KNEW BASS AND DID NOT
EMPOWER THE PARENTS.
THAT'S A PROBLEM BECAUSE AS WE
KNOW THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
YOU CAN DO FOR CHILD AND
EDUCATION IS APPARENT.
AND SECONDARY WITH THE TEACHER
AND THAT'S WHERE THE EMPHASIS
NEEDS TO BE IN THE IN THE
COMMUNITIES EMPOWER THEM.
THAT'S THE MESSAGE WE NEED TO
SEND DOWN AS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS TO
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT WE NEED TO
TALK TO OUR SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS.
EIGHT THIS IS YOURS IF YOU WANT
US TO SOLVE THE PROBLEM.
THAT WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
CATEGORICAL.
AND WE KNOW THAT DIDN'T WORK
[inaudible]
SO.
DON'T FEEL LIKE WE HAVE TO TAKE
THE BURDEN UPON OURSELVES UP
HERE.
THEY'RE RESPONSIBLE TO DO THEIR
SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THEIR
COMMUNITIES.
BECAUSE YOU OPPORTUNITIES AND
REDDING CALIFORNIA ARE DIFFERENT
THE BAKERSFIELD AND THEY'RE
DIFFERENT THAN IN CARLSBAD.
BECAUSE OF THE ECONOMICS IN THE
CULTURES OF THOSE COMMUNITIES.
I BELIEVE A GOVERNOR BROWN IN
THE WHAT WE'VE BEEN DOING AS FAR
AS LOCAL TROUGH FUNDING AL CAPP
[inaudible]
DASH BOARD.
TRANSPARENCY OR ALL GREAT THINGS
THAT WE NEED TO CONTINUE THAT
WAY.
BUT DON'T PUT IT ON US THAT WE
ARE THE DID THE FONT OF
KNOWLEDGE OR NOT.
GOVERNMENT IS BEST AT THE LOCAL
LEVEL AND WE NEED TO TALK TO OUR
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBERS ARE DUMB.
TAKE OWNERSHIP BUT THERE'S A
MAKE IT YOUR RESPONSIBILITY.
YOU DON'T WANT US INVOLVED IN
THAT AND SOMETIMES I THINK WE
WANT TO GET INVOLVED SAY.
THIS IS PRESCRIPTIVE DO A. B. C.
DAY [inaudible]
THAT'S THAT'S A FAILURE BECAUSE
ABC DAY AND WE'RE WRITING IS NOT
THE SAME AS IT IS AND BIGGEST
FAILURE CARLSBAD.
OKAY THANK YOU NEED TO I'M ASKS
FOR A REVISED MOTION CHI GET A
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL AS
AMENDED.
TAKE A SECOND.
THANK YOU.
SEE NO OTHER COMMENTS MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL THE
ROLL S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN FOUR TAKE PRIDE TING
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHáVEZ I CHIU.
CHOI.
CHOICE HIGH COOPER.
COOPER AYE FONG [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
COLORING [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
HIGHEST LACKEY I. MATHIS
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH A AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON.
REYES.
RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER.
WEBER I WOULD [inaudible]
WOULD I I FIFTEEN KNOW
[inaudible]
ZERO COLOR I THANK YOU LET'S
MOVE ONTO S. B. EIGHT SEVEN SIX
THIS IS OUR RESOURCES --
CLEANUP BILL.
WE HAVE MR AB WE ARE FROM
PERMITTED FINANCED PRESENT
[inaudible]
ASTRONOMER [inaudible]
SHARE MY CHAIR MEMBERS SERGIO I
GOT FROM THE FARM TO FINANCE
THIS TRAILER BILL INCLUDE
VARIOUS TECHNICAL AMENDMENTS --
NECESSARY TO EFFECTIVELY IMPLICA
LAW.
INCLUDES I THINK AMENDMENTS
RELATED TO LOS ANGELES THE RIVER
AND RECREATION PARK DISTRICT
WATER CONSERVATION THE DELTA
LEVY FOR VETERANS PROGRAM AND
THE PLASTICS MARKET DEVELOPMENT
PROGRAM.
THANK YOU ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ON S. B..
EIGHT SEVEN FIVE COULD NOT
SEEING ANY QUESTIONS GOING TO
PUBLIC COMMENT.
PUBLIC COMMENT A FAVORITE S. B.
SEVEN FIVE MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE I'LL WE
WHOLEHEARTEDLY THOUGHT REPRESENT
POETRY REPRESENTING THAT PLASTIC
RECYCLERS AND WE WHOLEHEARTEDLY
SUPPORT THIS WE NEEDED A
DEFINITIONAL CHANGE FOR THE PMDB
PAYMENTS --
BECAUSE OF THE LAST BILL THAT
WENT THROUGH IN THIS WILL HELP
US OUT HELP THOSE FIVE REMAINING
RECLAIMER RECYCLERS STAY IN
BUSINESS AND NOW MAKE THEIR
PAYMENTS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS WHERE TOP ON BEHALF OF
THE CITY OF SAN DIEGO WE ARE IN
SUPPORT OF SECTION FOUR OF THE
BELL IT'S A TECHNICAL CHANGE
CLEAN UP --
TO HELP OUR CITIES PURE WATER
PROJECT GET OFF THE GROUND WE
APPRECIATE YOUR SUPPORT THANK
YOU. TO GIVE YOU ANYONE ELSE IN
SUPPORT [inaudible]
ANY OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEE NONE COULD GET A MOTION
TO APPROVE.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL CHANGE AYE TING
AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I FURROW.
COME HERE [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I CHIU CHOI CHI CHOI AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER.
HARPER NO JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
COLOR.
LACKEY.
LACKEY I. MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ.
MULLIN DOES NO MULLIN MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH SHE AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RADIUS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
START HIGH VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD.
I CERTEON SNOW.
TO THE BILL HALL THINKING MOVING
FORWARD S. B. EIGHT SEVEN SIX
ARE HUMAN SERVICES.
BILL WE HAVE FIVE MISS SHELTON
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE 2% PLEASE
BEGIN WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THANK YOU THE CHURCH WHO DAILY
WITH THE PART OF FINANCE --
SO THIS CLEAN UP BILL MAKES
VARIOUS TECHNICAL AND CLARIFY
CHANGED TO HUMAN SERVICES
PROGRAM THAT WERE ADOPTED APART
AS PART THAT BUDGET ACT.
I'M LIKE THIS IS ALL JUST CLEAN
UP AND TECHNICAL SO MY CANNELLA
EVERY TOUCH UNLESS THERE'S ANY
QUESTIONS I'LL BE.
HAPPY TO ANSWERING THANK YOU ANY
QUESTIONS.
GREAT WIT MOTION A SECOND ANY
PUBLIC COMMENT IN FAVOR.
ANY PUBLIC COMMENT OPPOSED.
OKAY SEEING NONE MADAM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL.
I TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO.
CABALLERO.
CHAVEZ CHáVEZ AYE CHIU.
CHOI AYE CHOI AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
COLORING [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA MELENDEZ AYE MULLIN
MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH A AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO RUBIO AYE
STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE
WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
I THIRTEEN BILLS ARE HOT.
THANK YOU --
MOVING ON TO S. B. EIGHT SIX
NINE REGARDING GENERAL
GOVERNMENT IN ELECTIONS.
WITH MR CALLUM.
FROM DEPARTMENT FINANCE
PRESENTING PLEASE BEGIN.
PUT COME DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE --
SENATE BILL. EIGHT SIXTY NINE AS
A GENERAL GOVERNMENT TRAILER
BILL RELATED TO ELECTIONS THE
BILL CLARIFIES HOW THE
CALCULATION OF QUALIFIED
ELECTORS IS COMPUTED. FOR AN
AMENDMENT TO THE CHARTER --
OF THE SEA CAN'T COUNTY OF SAN
DIEGO AND OTHER RELATED CHANGES
ADDITIONALLY INCLUDES A FEDERAL
TRUST FUND AUGMENTATION AND I
WILL ALLOW THE SECRETARY OF
STATE TO SEND.
FEDERAL FUNDS TO THE COUNTIES TO
IMPROVE AND SECURE ELECTION
SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOCKED THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN SO I WAS
READING THE TITLE THE BILL SAYS
COUNTY OF SAN DIEGO.
LOCAL ELECTIONS.
WHAT DOES THAT HAVE TO DO WITH
THE BUDGET?
SO THE BILL INCLUDES AN
APPROPRIATION AND TO SEND MONEY
TO COUNTIES TO IMPROVE THEIR
ELECTION SYSTEMS AND I THINK
THAT'S GENERALLY IN THE
FRAMEWORK OF MAKING SURE
ELECTIONS.
HAPPEN THE WAY THAT THEIR
INTENDED TO AND I THINK THIS IS
RELATED TO PIECE OF LEGISLATION
THAT WAS DONE AT THE STATE LEVEL
TO SO.
AND IT'S A LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS
HIS SO THERE MIGHT BE COLLEAGUES
I COULD HE HOPED [inaudible]
ONE X. OKAY GOING I WOULD AGREE
WITH YOU THERE'S ONE LINE AT THE
END OF CONTAINS A SMALL
APPROPRIATION --
THE REST OF THE BILL I WOULD SAY
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH THE
BUDGET AND SO THE QUESTION I ASK
MYSELF IS.
WHY ARE WE CONSIDERING THIS BILL
IN BUDGET COMMITTEE AND I HAVE --
A VERY --
UNFORTUNATE ANSWER TO THAT
QUESTION AND MY ANSWER IS THAT
IT'S AN ATTEMPT BY.
THE LEGISLATURE TO INTERFERE
SORTS OF A LOCAL ELECTION.
AND Y. WITH THE LEGISLATURE
INTERFERE.
WELL IT'S A PARTISAN FIGHT AND
IF YOU DON'T BELIEVE ME LOOK IN
THE PREAMBLE OF THIS BILL UNLESS
THE COURT CASE.
THAT THEY'RE TRYING TO OVERTURN
THE PLAINTIFF IN THAT CASE
TWENTY TWO WORKERS THE CHAIRMAN
OF THE SAME WOULD HELP WITH THE
SAN DIEGO COUNTY REPUBLICAN
PARTY --
THIS IS BEING DONE RETROACTIVELY
WHICH IS COUNTER TO THE CUSTOM
PRACTICE OF THIS BODY
[inaudible]
AND YOU MIGHT ASK YOURSELF WHY
IS THIS A BUDGET BILL AND I
SUBMIT THE ONLY REASON WHY IT'S
BEING PROPOSED AS A BUDGET BILL.
IS THAT THAT'S THE ONLY WAY THAT
WE CAN APPLY THIS CHANGE WITH
IMMEDIATE EFFECT WITHOUT A TWO
THIRDS VOTE OF THE LEGISLATURE
AS THE CAN.
THE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES SO.
A GUY I THINK IT'S THIS IS A
DEPLORABLE INTERFERENCE ON A
LOCAL ELECTION.
I'M KIND OF A SHAME THAT WERE
DOING IT IS EXACTLY THIS KIND OF
ACTION.
THAT OUR ROADS OUR CONSTITUENTS
FAITH AND TRUST IN THE INTEGRITY
OF THEIR STATE GOVERNMENT.
I DON'T THINK IT HAS A PLACE.
IN A BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND AND
I HAVE MY APOLOGIES TO THERE'S
ALSO AN ASSOCIATED APPROPRIATION
IN THE BUDGET BILL JUNIOR
RELATED SIEU --
PROVIDING FUNDS TO THE COUNTY
RELATED TO THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
THIS LANGUAGE SO IT IT THERE IS --
BUDGET ASPECT --
ON THE FISCAL SIDE TO THE AND
ADMITTING THAT MY EARLIER TESTS
[inaudible]
OKAY [inaudible]
INSTRUMENTS.
AS I LIKED ALSO SPEAK ON THIS
I'M FROM SAN DIEGO THAT WATCH
THIS. ONE OF THE PROBLEMS I HAVE
WITH.
S. PROSELYTIZED BY LITTLE
EARLIER ON EDUCATION I WOULD DO
IT AGAIN.
POLICY BILLS WE HAVE POLICY
COMMITTEES THEY SHOULD DO IT
POLICIES THERE --
JUST BECAUSE WE CAN DOES NOT
MEAN THAT WE SHOULD.
AND I THINK THAT THIS BILL RIGHT
HERE.
IT IS A CLEAR EXAMPLE OF
OVERREACH INDIA AUTHORITY.
OF THIS BODY TO INFLUENCE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT.
THIS IS WRONG.
IS CLEARLY WRONG.
THIS SHOULD NOT BE BEING HEARD
[inaudible]
AND AND WHEN WE REFLECT BACK ON
OURSELVES.
THIS BILL RIGHT HERE SHOWS THE
PROBLEM IN SACRAMENTO.
WHAT WE'RE GOING THERE WE'RE
GOING TO USE OUR POLITICAL
INFLUENCE TO INFLUENCE SOMETHING
DOWN THERE IN THE REGION WE KNOW
WHY THE RESORT DOING THIS
BECAUSE?
THERE ARE LEADERS WITHIN THIS IS
SOMEBODY WHO COME FROM SAN DIEGO.
AND THEY ARE ABLE TO PUSH THESE
THINGS THROUGH.
AND THIS IS WRONG.
IF THIS A SUCH AN IMPORTANT
THING WE SHOULD HAVE BEEN DOING
IT TO THE COMMITTEE BUT DO YOU.
USE OUR MONEY. TO INFLUENCE
LOCAL POLITICS.
BECAUSE WE CAN [inaudible]
IS WRONG AND I'LL BE STRONGLY
VOTER YOU KNOW ABOUT THIS HOPE
THE PRESS IS WATCHING THIS HELP
DAN WALTERS WHO CAL MATTERS I
HOPE.
PODCAST COMES ON AND CAO CAO
WORKS WHAT'S GOING ON IN
SACRAMENTO.
EVERYBODY SPEAK UP TO SAYS YOU
KNOW WHAT.
IN THE BUDGET PROCESS AND
SACRAMENTO.
WE OVERSTATED OUR POSITION AND
THIS IS THE CLEAREST EXAMPLE.
OF ABUSE OF POWER [inaudible]
BY THIS.
BY THE LEADERSHIP OF THIS
ASSEMBLY [inaudible]
OKAY -- SEE
NO OTHER.
COMMENTS IN THE COMMITTEE TO THE
PUBLIC.
BUT WE HAVE --
IN SPIELBERG S. B..
EIGHT SIX NINE MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS TERRY BRENNAN ON BEHALF
VAST YEAH YOU CALIFORNIA AND
WITH ALL DUE RESPECT TO THE
OPPOSITION HERE [inaudible]
THIS.
CLARIFIED A TACTICAL AIR IN A
BILL THAT WAS ACTUALLY HEARD IN
BOTH HOUSES IN BOTH POLICY
COMMITTEES AND PASSED BY THIS
LEGISLATURE.
IN THE LAST SESSION. FOR THAT
REASON WE ARE TRANSPORT THANK
YOU.
MISS MANNERS.
I'M SORRY MISTER CHAIRMAN I JUST
WANTED TO CLARIFY THAT
ASSEMBLYMAN CHAVEZ ISN'T THE
OPPOSITION HE'S AN ASSEMBLY
MENTAL IT'S BE CLEAR WHEN WHERE
REFERENCING --
PEOPLE ON THE DIE IS --
IN ADDITION THIS IS A LABOR
BACKED.
CHARTER AMENDED PETITION THAT
FAILED TO GET ENOUGH SIGNATURES
ANALYSIS AND THEN RAN A LABOR
BACK DEADLINE TO TRY TO MAKE
THIS HAPPEN DODD IS EXACTLY
WHAT'S HAPPENING NO MATTER.
HOW YOU TRY TO DRESS IT UP I
THINK EVERYONE CAN SEE IT FOR
WHAT IT IS THANK YOU
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
S. B. [inaudible]
EIGHT SIX NINE OKAY.
CNN DOT EMOTION --
TO APPROVED SK.
EIGHT SIX NINE THANK YOU.
MOTION A SECOND I'M SECTOR TING.
AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM HIGH PEROT.
CABALLERO.
CHAVEZ NO CHáVEZ NO CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI NO CHOI YOU KNOW
COOPER.
COOPER AYE FONG.
FONG NO HARPER.
HARPER NO JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
LACKEY [inaudible]
MATHIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN HAS NO MULLIN
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
APPEL NO WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD.
I SIX SEVEN YOUNG TO BILLS ON
THE CALL.
FAKE YOU --
MOVING FORWARD AS BEAT SEVEN
SEVEN IT'S ADDITIONAL GENERAL
GOVERNMENT --
BUDGET CLARIFICATION ON BUDGET
CLEAN UP.
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE MISTER
THOMPSON'S REPRESENT.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS MARK OLSON DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE I'M S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
SEVEN IS THE GENERAL GOVERNMENT
TRAILER BILL.
ON THIS MAKES TECHNICAL CLEAN UP
TO ESPY'S NINETY SIX OF TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WHICH CHANGE TIMELINES
AND REQUIREMENTS FOR AWARDING
BODIES.
TO NOTIFY THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS A PUBLIC
WORKS PROJECTS.
IT ADDRESSES CONCERNS RAISED IN
INSTANCES OF EMERGENCY WORK AND
ALLOWS A WARNING BODIES AFTER
THIRTY DAYS AFTER THE AWARD OF A
CONTRACT TO SUBMIT THIS
INFORMATION TO THE AYE ARE.
THE BILL ALSO EXEMPTS CONTRACTS
RELATED TO THE TWENTY TWENTY
CENTS IS COMPLETE COUNT FROM THE
PUBLIC CONTRACTING PROCESS.
ALLOWS A CD TO COLLECT LONG TERM
HONORING FEES FOR THE HOUSING
FOR HEALTHY CALIFORNIA PROGRAM.
AND EXTENDS A REPAYMENT DATE OF
THE CASTLE LOAN MADE TO MASS
TRANSIT PROVIDERS OF FROM THE
PUBLIC TRANSPORTATION ACCOUNT.
UNTIL JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY ONE AND WITH THAT I'M
HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
I THINK YOU COME BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS.
THE MOTION TO HAVE A SECOND.
ALLEN MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN FAVOR
OF SB.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN GOOD AFTERNOON
ROUND ROSSI WITH THE CALIFORNIA
SPECIAL DISTRICTS ASSOCIATION
HERE IN SUPPORT OF THE EMERGENCY
CONTRACTING PROVISIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYONE ELSE'S SPORT.
ANY OPPOSITION TO SB.
EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN OKAY SINGER
NOR THE QUESTIONS MADAM
SECRETARY CRITICAL.
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I THROW CABALLERO.
CHáVEZ.
CHAVEZ I CHU.
CHU AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FALL.
FONG I HARPER.
HARPER HIGH JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
LACKEY.
MATHIS LACKEY AYE [inaudible]
NOW THIS [inaudible]
MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA [inaudible]
MELENDEZ.
MELINDA I MULLIN MURATSUCHI
O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO.
BROUGH WHERE AYE STONE.
STONE I VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WEBER WOOD.
I SEE FORTINO ZERO THANK YOU --
MOVE FORWARD WE'RE MOVING ON TO
S. B. EIGHT SIX ONE RICH AS
REGARDING A MORTGAGE SETTLEMENT
[inaudible]
DISCOVER.
JOSH DUGGAR DEPARTMENT FINANCE
AND SENATE BILL EIGHT SIXTY ONES
A BUDGET TRAILER BILL AND WHICH
CLARIFIES ALLOCATIONS BY THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE FROM THE
NATIONAL MORTGAGE SPECIAL
DEPOSIT FUND IN 200-011-1212
THIRTEEN AND THIRTEEN FOURTEEN
WERE CONSISTENT WITH LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTION PROVIDED IN GOVERNMENT
CODE SECTION. ONE TWO FIVE THREE
ONE SUBDIVISION <c.green> ENACTING</c>
THIS CLARIFICATION IS ALSO THE
INTENT TO ABROGATE THE HOLDING
OF THE COURT OF APPEALS RELATED
TO THIS MATTER.
HAVE TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS YOU
MAY HAVE.
I THINK MISTER.
THANK YOU ACTUALLY I AS YOU'VE
JUST REFERENCE SOMETHING THAT I
WANTED TO ASK ABOUT BECAUSE I
DIDN'T SEE IN THE ANALYSIS AND I
JUST -- WAS
A PRIZE THAT THIS DOES IMPACT --
AN APPELLATE COURT RULING THAT
JUST CAME DOWN A FEW WEEKS AGO
SO MY UNDERSTANDING IS.
A FEW YEARS AGO THE LEGISLATURE
DECIDED --
THAT -- THIS
WOULD BE THE WAY TO GO AS
OPPOSED.
INTENT OF THE SETTLEMENT FUND
WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO AND AND IS
IS THIS LANGUAGE PART OF ANY
AGREEMENT AROUND THE LAWSUIT OR
HOW DOES THIS.
IMPACT LAWSUIT IT'S IT'S THE
POSITION OF THE GOVERNOR THAT
THIS.
AGGREGATES THE LAWSUIT AND AND
IF WE TAKE THIS POSITION THAT
THOUGHT THAT THIS WILL PREVAIL
IN COURTS COULD YOU JUST WALK ME
THROUGH HOW THIS IMPACTS THE
LAWSUIT.
SO IT IT'S ARE --
POSITION --
THAT THE OPINION THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING HINGES ON THE THE
FACT THAT OR THE FINDING THAT
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE
MISINTERPRETED THE LEGISLATIVE A
DIRECTION OF THE LEGISLATURE'S
DIRECTION IN ENACTING --
THE CURRENT STATUTE SO --
THIS IS MEANT TO CLARIFY THAT
THE ALLOCATIONS MADE BY THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCE WHERE IN
FACT CONSISTENT WITH THAT
LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION AND I
THINK THAT --
IT'S OUR POSITION THAT THAT YOU
KNOW FURTHER MADE CLEAR BY THE
FACT THAT THE DIRECTOR OF
FINANCE ALSO ACCORDING TO
CURRENT.
A STATUTE --
WAS REQUIRED TO SUBMIT --
SCHEDULES AND PLANS TO THE JOINT
LEGISLATIVE BUDGET COMMITTEE FOR
REVIEW AND THEN IN SUBSEQUENT.
FISCAL YEARS INCLUDED --
THE ADDITIONAL ALLOCATIONS IN
THE BUDGET THAT WAS A APPROVED
ENACTED BY THE LEGISLATURE SO
IT'S OUR POSITION THAT THIS
ADDRESSES THE CURRENT OPINION --
BUT I THERE'S ALSO LIKELY --
A SEEKING OF A REVIEW BY THE
SOME SUPREME COURT ON THE MATTER
AS WELL.
OKAY TO SO AND AND IS IS WHAT WE
ARE DOING HERE IS THIS DIFFERENT
FROM WHAT THE LEGISLATURE DID
SOME YEARS BACK.
I KNOW SO THIS IS --
STRICTLY CLARIFYING THAT THE
ALLOCATIONS --
THAT WERE MADE AFTER THE
LEGISLATURE ENACTED THE THE
PRIOR STATUE THAT YOU'RE
REFERENCING WORK CONSISTENT WITH
THAT STATUTE AND FOR FOR IT FOR
THE SAKE OF THE DISCUSSION THE
CURRENT STATUTE READS
NOTWITHSTANDING ANY OTHER LAW.
THE DIRECTOR OF FINANCE MAY
ALLOCATE OR OTHER THE NATIONAL
MORTGAGE SPECIAL DEPOSIT FUND
OFFSET GENERAL FUND EXPENDITURES
IN THE THREE FISCAL YEARS
MENTIONED.
OKAY THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IN THIS OR NOT I THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIR SO.
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT QUESTION.
IS IT YOUR OPINION THAT.
THE EXPENDITURE OF THOSE FUNDS
OUT OF THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE
SPECIAL DEPOSIT FUND.
WERE.
A A LEGAL USE OF THE NATIONAL
MORTGAGE FUND --
MONEY.
SO IT IN ANSWERING THAT QUESTION
I THINK IT'S MAYBE FIRST
IMPORTANT KIND OF SET THE STAGE
IN THE BACKGROUND ON THE IS CHAU
SO IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE THERE
WAS A SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT TO
PROVIDE TWENTY BILLION DOLLARS --
IN RELIEF DIRECTLY TO CONSUMERS --
ALSO THERE WAS A SEPARATE PART
OF A SEPARATE POT OF MONEY AS
PART OF THAT SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT THAT WAS INTENDED TO
COMPENSATE.
US STATES THEMSELVES --
FOR DAMAGES AND THAT WAS YOU
KNOW. FOR EXAMPLE PROPERTIES
PROPERTY TAX LOSSES INCOME TAX
LOSSES EXPENDITURES THAT STATES
MADE -- TO
SUPPORT THE CONSTITUENTS OTHER
STATE -- AS
CITIZENS OF THEIR STATE AND
OVERALL ECONOMIC IMPACT SO --
THE POT OF MONEY THAT WE'RE JUST
[inaudible]
SUBJECT --
IN THE LAWSUIT IS THAT SECOND
PART OF MONEY THAT WAS FOR THE
STATE'S --
AND IT THIS --
DECISION WAS --
DURING THE RECESSION AND
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED A FOUR
HUNDRED AND TEN MILLION DOLLARS
OF THAT AND POT OF MONEY AND THE
STATE ATTORNEY GENERALS WERE
BASICALLY --
I IN SOME STATES WEIGHED IN WITH
THEIR INTENT OF HOW THESE FUNDS
WOULD BE USED --
THE CALIFORNIA ATTORNEY GENERAL
WEIGHED IN WITH A INTENT ON HOW
THE FUNDS SHOULD BE USED --
HOWEVER --
THE STATE WAS FACED WITH THE
RECESSION AND UNDERGOING DEEP
BUDGET CUTS AT THE TIME AND SO
THE STATE DID THE BEST --
THAT IT COULD --
TO ALLOCATE RESOURCES CONSISTENT
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S --
INTENT AND I THINK THAT THAT THE
COURT AND HAS --
AGREED THAT SOME OF THE
ALLOCATION OF THE FOUR HUNDRED
TEN MILLION IT WAS CONSISTENT
WITH THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S.
INTENT --
BUT THESE SO MADE --
IN CONJUNCTION WITH --
THE RECESSION AND COMPETING
PRIORITIES AT THE TIME AND
TRYING TO AVOID --
EVEN DEEPER BUDGET CUTS AND AND
AGAIN WERE MADE AND CONSISTENT
WITH THE LEGISLATIVE DIRECTION
PROVIDED IN THE STATUTE.
YOU SEE VERY WELL INFORMED ON
THIS.
HAVE YOU READ.
THE NATIONAL MORTGAGE FUNDS
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENTS
SPECIFICALLY THE LANGUAGE THAT
SPECIFIES WHAT THE PURPOSE OF
THAT MONEY GIVEN TO THE STATES
SHOULD BE.
I'M NOT SURE THAT I COULD SPEAK
TO THE EXACT LANGUAGE --
RIGHT NOW I COULD GIVE YOU AYE
PERHAPS --
OVERVIEW OF THE CONSENT DECREE
OF THE ATTORNEY GENERAL'S INTENT
OF FOR THE USE OF THE FUNDS ATOP
AT THE FEDERAL SETTLEMENT
AGREEMENT AND THAT LET ME LET ME
READ YOU THE RELEVANT PIECES
BECAUSE THIS IS.
BUT WHAT THE COURT CASE WAS
TRYING TO DECIDE WHETHER OR NOT.
THE STATE'S EXPENDITURE OF THAT
MONEY COMPLIED WITH THIS TERM OF
THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT.
OUR AND THE SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT
SAYS SUCH FINE SHALL BE USED. TO
AVOID PREVENTABLE FORECLOSURES
TO AMELIORATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS TO ENHANCE
LAW ENFORCEMENT EFFORTS TO
PREVENT AND PROSECUTE FINANCIAL
FRAUD.
OR UNFAIR OR DECEPTIVE ACTS AND
PRACTICES AND A COMPETENT IT'S
COMPENSATE THE STATES FOR THE
COSTS RESULTING FROM THE ALLEGED
OUGHT UNLAWFUL CONTACT OF THE
DEFENDANTS.
SO THE APPEALS COURT SEGMENTED
THOSE EXPENDITURES.
AND THEY'VE DECIDED THAT OF THE
FOREIGN TEN MILLION DOLLARS A
CALIFORNIA RECEIVED --
THREE HUNDRED AND THIRTY ONE
MILLION DOLLARS.
SHOULD HAVE GONE TO FORECLOSURE
RELIEF AND THE REST.
WAS FREE THE STATE WAS FREE TO
USE AS IT INTO --
ITSELF IT BECAUSE THAT PORTION
COMPENSATED THE STATE'S FOR ITS
COSTS SO WE'RE HERE TALKING
ABOUT THE THREE HUNDRED AND
THIRTY ONE MILLION DOLLARS AND I
DON'T SEE HOW WE CAN POSSIBLY
ARGUE.
THAT THAT MONEY SHOULDN'T GO. TO
AMELIORATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS AS A
SETTLEMENT AGREEMENT IS DICTATED.
SO I I'D I DON'T I'M NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW YOU CAN ARGUE.
WITH SOMETHING SO FORTHRIGHT.
WHAT IF I THINK I JUST WANTED TO
CLARIFY THAT THE LANGUAGE --
AND CLARIFICATION THAT'S PART OF
THIS TRAILER BILL --
IS IN RESPONSE --
TO THE THE OPINION THAT --
SPECIFICALLY HINGES ON FOR THE
DIRECTOR OF FINANCES
MISINTERPRETATION OF THE
LEGISLATURE'S DIRECTION AND THAT
IS WHAT WE ARE --
INTENDING TO ADDRESS WHERE FOR
THIS I DON'T UNDERSTAND AND
YOU'RE YOU'RE ASKING OF AND YOU
KNOW FOR FOR ALL OF US THERE TRY
TO MAKE THIS DECISION A PART OF
THIS BILL SAYS.
THAT THE LEGISLATURE WAS AWARE
OF AND APPROVED THE ALLOCATION
OF THOSE FUNDS THAT'S IT THAT'S
A LANGUAGE IN THE BILL WERE
VOTING ON SO WE HAVE TO DECIDE.
DO WE APPROVE OF THAT OUR AND IT
SAYS EXPLICITLY WHEN THE STATE
WAS GIVEN THAT MONEY THAT WERE
SUPPOSED TO GIVE IT. TO
AMELIORATE THE EFFECTS OF THE
FORECLOSURE CRISIS WHICH IS NOT
SPENDING IT.
BOND BY FIXING THE DEFICIT OF
OUR STATE DEPARTMENTS
[inaudible]
SO.
I I THINK IT'S IT'S IAM
INCREDULOUS.
THAT WERE BEING ASKED TO TAKE
THIS ACTION --
YOU KNOW I UNDERSTAND THAT THE
ADMINISTRATION'S KIND OF IN A
LITTLE HOLE HERE BECAUSE THEY'VE
GOT THIS ADVERSE APPEALS COURT
RULING.
BUT I'M CERTAINLY NOT GOING TO
BE COMPLICIT [inaudible]
IN.
GIVEN MY APPROVAL TO SOMETHING
THAT I THINK IS WRONG AND I
THINK THAT THAT THREE AND THIRTY
ONE MILLION DOLLARS ABSOLUTELY
SHOULD GO TO THE VICTIMS.
A OF THAT FORECLOSURE CRISIS AND
NOT TO THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
AND I WOULD.
STRONGLY ENCOURAGE ALL MY
COLLEAGUES TO VOTE AGAINST THIS
BILL THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE
NEED TO GIVE.
OUR OUR PRINTER TO THIS
DEPLORABLE ACTION.
THINK ANYONE ELSE ON SPELL.
A MEMBERS THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
EIGHT SIX ONE MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC IN OPPOSITION TO S. B.
SIX WERE.
GO GET A MOTION AND A SECOND TO
APPROVE SP AT SIX ONE DURING THE
SECOND [inaudible]
MEN'S LOCKER.
KING I'VE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE NO ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BRO [inaudible]
BLOOM I BROUGH [inaudible]
COME HERE [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI NO CHOI YOU KNOW
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG NO HARPER NO HARPER NO
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
LACKEY.
LACKEY NO MATHIS.
NOW THERE'S NO MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ BELINDA'S NO
MULLIN MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE STONE AYE VOEPEL
NO VOEPEL NO WEBER.
WOOD [inaudible]
WHAT I? EIGHT AYE YES EIGHT
KNOWS THE ALSO CALL.
THANK YOU MOVED ON TO SB.
EIGHT SIX SEVEN I REGARDING
LEGISLATIVE WORKPLACE CONDUCT
MISTER KALB.
SENATE BILL EIGHT SIX SEVEN IS A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL THAT
REQUIRES THE LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL
TO ESTABLISH A UNIT WITHIN THE
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL BUREAU. TO
PROVIDE ADVICE AND INVESTIGATION
SERVICES TO THE LEGISLATURE
RELATED TO WORKPLACE MISCONDUCT --
THERE'S OTHER REQUIREMENTS
INCLUDED IN THE LANGUAGE AND
THERE'S ONE POINT FIVE MILLION
DOLLARS GENERAL FUND AND
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN FOR
IMPLEMENTATION COST OF THE UNIT.
MOVE THE BILL.
I CAN I GET A MOTION TO MOVE THE
BILL AS AMENDED.
MOTION TO MOVE THE BILL AS
AMENDED THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD ARE ANY COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE MIS MANOS.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I'LL
BE BRIEF I JUST I JUST WANTED TO
SAY THAT --
I I'M SURE I'M SURE IT I HAVE
OTHERS WHO WOULD AGREE WITH ME
THAT I AM ABSOLUTELY DISGUSTED.
WAITER APPROPRIATE ONE AND A
HALF MILLION DOLLARS FOR THIS
BECAUSE FRANKLY THEY SHOULD NOT
BE SOMETHING WE WOULD NEED TO
SPEND MONEY ON AYE IT'S AMAZING
TO ME THAT.
PEOPLE CAN'T QUITE FIGURE OUT
HOW TO CONDUCT THEMSELVES
PROPERLY AT WORK --
BUT NONE THE LESS HERE WE ARE
APPROPRIATING THIS MONEY WHICH
I'M SURE WILL BE --
WELL SPENT AND I HAVE THIS
STRANGE FEELING IN THE FUTURE
FOR SOME REASON WE'RE GOING TO
BE ASKED TO SPEND EVEN MORE
MONEY ON THIS TOPIC BECAUSE
PEOPLE DON'T KNOW HOW TO BEHAVE
THEMSELVES AT WORK SEPT --
I WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU TO THE COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
ANY MEMBERS OF PUBLIC IN SUPPORT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY WE HAVE A MOTION.
AND A SECOND THEM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE.
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
WHOM I BROKE [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I FLUNKED.
FONG I HARPER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KALRA AYE LACKEY ARTIST LACKEY
HI MATHIS.
MATHIS TYPE MCCARTY [inaudible]
MEDINA.
DO KNOW I'VE MELENDEZ MULLIN
DOES AYE MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE I VOEPEL AYE VOEPEL AYE
WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
WHAT I [inaudible]
HARPER I THEY CAN MOVE IT ON TO
S. B. --
EIGHT SEVEN EIGHT FILM TAX
CREDIT CLEANUP [inaudible]
WHICH GENERAL.
THANK YOU --
ANTECHAMBER DEPARTMENT FINANCE --
SB EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT AND I
MAKE SOME TECHNICAL.
OUR CLEAN UP TO THE TO THE FILM
CREDIT EXTENSION THAT WAS PASSED
PART OF THE BUDGET AS AS A
BUDGET TRAILER BILL.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY ONE HOW DOES
THREE THINGS FIRST HOLE CHANGES
DATE FOR THE OLEO --
SECONDLY IT CLARIFIES WHAT
UNUSED CREDITS WILL --
THE COMMISSION THE FILM
COMMISSION WILL BE ALLOWED TO
ALLOCATE AFTER OF THE JULY ONE
TWENTY FOUR TWENTY FIVE PART.
JULY.
ONE TWENTY FIVE TWO THOUSAND
TWENTY FIVE AND THEN THIRD MAKES
AN APPROPRIATION TO THE FILM
COMMISSION OF FIVE THOUSAND
DOLLARS --
TO FOR DRAFTING RULES FOR
IMPLEMENTING THE FROM.
I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS THINK ANY QUESTIONS
WITH US.
SEEING NO QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE ANY MEMBERS OF THE BUT
THE SUPPORT OF SB A SEVEN EIGHT
HOW MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS TERRY
THOMAS SOME WE HAVE THE MOTION
PICTURE ASSOCIATION OF AMERICA
WERE IN SUPPORT OF THESE
AMENDMENTS THAT ARE.
REQUESTED BY THE LA ON THE
DEPARTMENT OF FINANCE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANYBODY ELSE IN
SUPPORT.
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
WE HAVE A MOTION TO HAVE THE
SECOND SECOND MA'AM SECRETARY
COULD YOU CALL THE ROLL PLEASE
[inaudible]
TING.
TING I OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA
[inaudible]
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO.
CARRERA [inaudible]
CHAVEZ CHU CHU AYE CHOI AYE CHOI
AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR I LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MATHIS AYE MATHIS AYE
MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES
AYE MULLIN MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL TYPE VOEPEL AYE
WEBER.
WOOD.
WHAT I AYE?
SIXTEEN MOVING FORWARD I SP
EIGHT SEVEN NINE PUBLIC SAFETY
CLEAN UP BILL MISTER CARVER.
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN NINE IS THE
PUBLIC SAFETY OF BUDGET TRAILER
BILL AT THIS BILL INCLUDES FOUR
MAIN COMPONENTS THE FIRST
CLARIFIES THAT THE TWO NEW NEWLY
AUTHORIZED JUDGESHIPS --
IN THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET --
COME OUT OF THE FIFTY THAT WERE
PREVIOUSLY AUTHORIZED IN STATUTE
REDUCING THE OVERALL A NUMBER A
YET TO BE AUTHORIZED OR AVAIL
ARE MADE AVAILABLE.
TO FORTY EIGHT OF THE SECOND
MAIN COMPONENT APPROPRIATES FIVE
MILLION DOLLARS IN UNSPENT FUNDS
FROM THE PEACE OFFICER TRAINING
FUND FOR REIMBURSEMENT TO LOCAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT FOR PEACE
OFFICER TRAINING.
OF THE THIRD --
COMPONENT THE BILL CLARIFIES
EXISTING STATUTE RELATED --
TO THE PUBLIC DISCLOSURE OF
INFORMATION BY THE CALIFORNIA
STATE AUDITOR AND FINALLY --
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT THE THE
MEDICAL RESPONSE CERTIFICATION
PROCESS FOR PAROLEES ARE
PARTICIPATING IN THE CALIFORNIA
OR TRAINING PROGRAM IS NON
PROVISIONAL.
UP TO ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS.
ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE COMMITTEE
[inaudible]
IT'S MEDINA.
DOES DOES THE LANGUAGE SPECIFY
WHERE THE JUDGES ARE --
THE SO THE TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
NINETEEN BUDGET AUTHORIZED A TWO
NEW JUDGESHIPS IN --
THE COUNTY OF RIVERSIDE
[inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THINK ANY OTHER QUESTIONS.
ANY MEMBERS REPUBLICAN SUPPORT.
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION.
OKAY SEEN NANKAI GET A MOTION
AND A SECOND TO APPROVE.
THANK YOU MA'AM SECTOR.
TING AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ CHU CHU HI CHOI AYE CHOI
AYE COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER.
JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
COLOR AYE LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE MATHIS.
NOW THIS AYE MCCARTY MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES
AYE MULLIN MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL
PATTERSON RADIUS RUBIO
[inaudible]
RUBIO AYE [inaudible]
STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL THANKED VOEPEL
AYE WEBER WOOD [inaudible]
WOULD I MY SIXTY THANK YOU
MOVING FORWARD TO S. B. --
EIGHT FOUR SIX GENERAL
GOVERNMENT [inaudible]
LABOR [inaudible]
BUILT.
REPORTER ALISON THE BARMAN
FINANCE MUST BE A PRETTY SIX
HOURS IS WHEN THE TRAINING
TRAILER BILL.
OF THIS BILL LOVES KELLY CHARTER
PUBLISHES EFFORTS RELATED TO
REASONABLE ACCOMMODATION POLICY
IMPROVEMENTS INTO AN EXISTING
REPORT TO THE LEGISLATURE.
ZOO NOVEMBER FIFTEENTH OF EACH
YEAR AND RECORD CDS A PUBLISHED
ON ITS WEBSITE A STATE PURCHASES
THE RESULT IN REASONABLE
ACCOMMODATION.
ON THIS BILL ALSO MAKES
CLARIFICATIONS REGARDING THE
AUTHORITY OF THE KERN COUNTY
EMPLOYERS ASSOCIATION BOARD.
AND APPROPRIATE ONE POINT THREE
MILLION THE FEDERAL FUNDS --
TO ALLOW THE DEPARTMENT OF
INDUSTRIAL RELATIONS TO RECEIVE
AN IMPRESSIVE BICU SA GRANT
FOR EFFORTS TO SUPPORT EXISTING.
AND EXPANDS NEW APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS.
WITH THAT I'M HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS.
GREAT ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SINGLE QUESTIONS WE HAVE A
MOTION [inaudible]
LIVE SOCCER.
SORT MOTION WE ARE MUCH SECOND I
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN SUPPORT
OF SB.
EIGHT FOUR SIX ANYBODY FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC AGAINST SB.
EIGHT FOUR SIX SEEING NONE MADAM
SECRETARY COULD YOU CALL
RIPLEY'S [inaudible]
TING.
I TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE GROW.
BROUGH AYE FOR THE ERA
[inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI AYE CHOI AYE
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG [inaudible]
HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
COLOR.
CLARA AYE LACKEY AYE LACKEY AYE
NOW THIS.
NOW THIS AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ MELENDEZ AYE
MULLIN.
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS.
FREE AS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD.
WOULD I ICT.
THANK YOU --
WE'RE GONNA ASK CHRISTIAN
GRIFFITH LE CHIEF CONSULTANT FOR
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE TO PRESENT
THE THREE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORT
LANGUAGES WOULD JUST TAKE THAT
AS A GROUP.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THERE
THREE PIECES OF SUPPLY REPORT
BEFORE THE COMMITTEE.
I THESE ARE REPORTING LANGUAGE
PIECES THEIR NON CODIFIED THE
DEALIO.
I TRACKS --
THAT WOULD ALLOW US TO DO OVER
SAY THE FUTURE THE FIRST.
ONE I INVOLVES ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES AND ASK FOR DATA.
RELATED TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE
CHARGING AND ALSO LIKE TO THE
ELECTRIC VEHICLE HOT SALES FOR
PURPOSES OF PROJECTING THAT THE
CRP PROGRAM.
THE SECOND PROVISION IS REQUEST
THE DEPARTMENT OF PARKS
RECREATION TO ASSIST IN
IDENTIFYING THE FISCAL AGENT FOR
USE OF FUNDS SET ASIDE TO
REBUILD A COMMUNITY CENTER IT'S
NUMBER COUNTY.
I AND THE THIRD ONE EXPRESSES
THE LEGISLATIVE INTENT TO WORK
WITH THE INCOMING ADMINISTRATION
TO MOVE THE MAY REVISION RELEASE
STATE EARLIER IN THE CALENDAR TO
ALLOW.
US TO CHANGE OUR BUDGET PROCESS.
I THINK ANY QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE [inaudible]
IT WILL --
ANY MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
[inaudible]
SUPPORT.
THE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC IN
OPPOSITION [inaudible]
WE HAVE.
WITH PARTNER FINANCE WANTING
[inaudible]
TO SPEAK [inaudible]
PLEASE.
AMANDA MARTIN DEPARTMENT OF
FINANCE --
ON THE SUBMIT REPORT LANGUAGE
RELATED TO ZERO EMISSION VEHICLE.
INFRASTRUCTURE --
WE DID RECEIVE LANGUAGE LATE
LAST NIGHT WE ARE REVIEWING IT
I'M WE CANNOT SUPPORT THIS
PORTION OFFICE [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
SO I WOULD LIKE TO GET A MOTION
AND A SECOND FOR JUST THE ZERO
EMISSION VEHICLE I WHICH RIGHT
NOW [inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M SECRETARY COULD CALL THE
ROLL TING.
AYE TING AYE OBERNOLTE.
OBERNOLTE AYE ARAMBULA.
BLUE ARAMBULA AYE BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE BRO [inaudible]
BRUNO CUMPLIR [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI NO CHOI NO COOPER.
COOPER I FALL.
FONG NO HARPER.
HARPER KNOWN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY NO LACKEY NO
MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES NO MULLIN
MURATSUCHI [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
PATTERSON RADIUS.
PRE AS I RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL NO WEBER.
WOOD.
PRICE TAG KNOWS A THINK YOU CAN
GET A MOTION TO APPROVE THE
OTHER TWO ITEMS REGARDING SONOMA
COUNTY IN THE BUDGET PROCESS.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY.
I CAN HIGH.
OBERNOLTE OBERNOLTE AYE.
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I BLUE.
BLOOM AYE BRO.
BROUGH BRO I CABALLERO
[inaudible]
TRAVIS [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE CHOI [inaudible]
COOPER.
COOPER I FONG.
FONG I HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR AYE LACKEY.
NOW THAT LACKEY I NOW THIS NOW
THIS AYE MCCARTY.
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN DOES AYE MULLIN
MURATSUCHI O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS REYES AYE RUBIO.
RUBIO AYE STONE.
STONE AYE VOEPEL.
VOEPEL I WEBER.
WOOD [inaudible]
I SEVENTY CHOI AYE.
THANK YOU ARE AT THAT TIME TO
THE SOLDIERS CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS WERE GONNA RUN THROUGH
AND TO ADD ONS RIGHT NOW SO
MADAM SECRETARY.
FEEL FREE TO BEGIN WITH THAT
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I MET MADAM SECRETARY FEW FRITO
START AT ARMS.
OF PEOPLE WHO WORK HERE.
NOT ENOUGH.
ON SB EIGHT SIX TO DO PASS AS
AMENDED [inaudible]
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE.
BRO [inaudible]
BROKE NO [inaudible]
CHIU [inaudible]
CHIU I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
PATTERSON STONE.
STONE I WOULD
.
ON S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY FOR THE
MOTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
ARAMBULA I BRO.
YEAH BRO NOW COPIER [inaudible]
CHIU.
CHIU AYE FONG [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
NOW THIS.
NOW THAT'S NOT VOTING MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MELENDEZ
[inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE.
PATTERSON RANTS RAY AS I ICE.
TWENTY ONE ONE NO ONE NOT VOTING.
MIKE ESPY EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ARAMBULA.
REBEL AYE BRO.
ROSE NO CUT THEIR CHIU.
CHIU AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
KALRA.
COLOR AYE MATHIS [inaudible]
PARTY.
I I SPEAK.
SEVENTY FIVE NOW THIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON
[inaudible]
RAY THIS [inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD.
S. P. EIGHT SEVENTY SIX THE
MOTION IS TO PASS ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BRO.
BROUGH AYE CABALLERO.
CHU.
CHU AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
KALRA.
KALRA KILEY LACKEY.
LACKEY AYE NOW THIS.
MATHIS I MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
O'DONNELL [inaudible]
MULLIN I O'DONNELL [inaudible]
RAY YES.
REYES AYE WEBER [inaudible]
WOULD [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I S. B. EIGHT SIXTY
NINE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BRO.
BRO NO CABALLERO [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
CHOLERA.
COLOR HIGH LACKEY NO.
LACKEY NO MATHIS.
MATHIS NO MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA [inaudible]
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON RADIUS
[inaudible]
WEBER [inaudible]
WHAT?
ON S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY SEVENTH
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
ARAMBULA.
REBEL I BROKE.
BRO I CABALLERO [inaudible]
JONES SAWYER [inaudible]
KALRA.
CLARA AYE MATHIS.
NOW THIS AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA I IMMERSE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH A AYE O'DONNELL
[inaudible]
PATTERSON [inaudible]
RAY YES.
GRAY AS I WEBER [inaudible]
WHAT [inaudible]
O'DONNELL I ON S. B. EIGHT SIX
ONE THE MOTION IS TO PASS
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I A BRO.
BROUGH NO CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHáVEZ NO JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
KALRA [inaudible]
KALRA AYE [inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE.
MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH SHE AYE O'DONNELL.
PATTERSON RADIUS RADIUS I WEBER
[inaudible]
O'DONNELL I MIKE ESPY EIGHT SIX
SEVEN ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE BRO.
BROUGH AYE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
TRY THIS.
CHAVEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON RADIUS.
THE RADIUS AYE WEBER.
MIKE ESPY EIGHT SEVENTY EIGHT
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA HI BRO.
BROUGH AYE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
JOHN THIS.
CHáVEZ AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
MURATSUCHI AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON RADIUS.
REYES AYE WEBER.
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN NINE ARAMBULA.
RAMMELL I BRO.
BRO I CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHáVEZ AYE HARPER.
HARPER AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER HEIGHT MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN YE MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH SHE AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON WEBER.
MIKE ESPY EIGHT FOUR SIX
ARAMBULA [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ AYE JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN I MURATSUCHI MURATSUCHI
AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON WEBER
[inaudible]
FONG I THIS IS FOR THE
SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING LANGUAGE
ON THEIR A ZERO EMISSION
VEHICLES [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
JONES SAWYER JONES SAWYER AYE
[inaudible]
MCCARTY.
MCCARTY AYE MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MULLIN.
MULLIN AYE MURATSUCHI.
RESEARCH A AYE O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
WEBER WOOD [inaudible]
POLICY CHAVEZ [inaudible]
NO.
AND THIS FOR THE PARTS YOU OF
THE SUPPLEMENTAL REPORTING
LANGUAGE [inaudible]
BLOOM [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHAVEZ [inaudible]
CHáVEZ I JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE MCCARTY
[inaudible]
MEDINA.
MEDINA AYE MELENDEZ [inaudible]
MULLIN [inaudible]
MULLIN I WE'RE MURATSUCHI AYE
O'DONNELL.
O'DONNELL AYE PATTERSON.
WEBER.
WHAT I'M STONE [inaudible]
WEBER WOOD
.
NINE AB AS SPEAK SIX NINE MEDINA
AYE
.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY FIVE JONES
SAWYER.
THAT'S WHERE I FIFTY EIGHT
SEVENTY SIX JONES SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
S. B. EIGHT SIX NINE JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY SEVEN JONES
SAWYER.
JONES SAWYER AYE PESKY EIGHT SIX
ONE JONES SAWYER --
I S. B..
EIGHT SIX S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT JONES SAWYER.
JOHN FOR YOUR I SP
.
EIGHT PINE S. B. FIFTEEN SIXTY
NINE RESEARCHING [inaudible]
MURATSUCHI I
S. B. SIX NINE WHAT [inaudible]
WHAT I?
S. B. EIGHT SEVEN SEVEN WHAT
[inaudible]
WHEN I [inaudible]
THAT'S ON THAT SUPPLEMENTAL OF
REPORTING LANGUAGE WHAT
[inaudible]
WHAT I'VE [inaudible]
AND THERE'S WHAT.
NO NO NO COLLEGES [inaudible]
MISS [inaudible]
I MEAN [inaudible]
SCULLY ARE.
S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY FOUR
CABALLERO.
CLICK HERE I SB THIRTY FIVE
CLEAR I S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY SIX
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CLEAR I S. B. EIGHT SEVENTY
SEVEN FIVE A YEAR [inaudible]
CLEAR I S. B. EIGHT SIX ONE
COMING ERA.
COME HERE I S. B. EIGHT SIX
SEVEN CABALLERO [inaudible]
CLEAR I THAT'S BE EIGHT SEVENTY
EIGHT CABALLERO.
COME HERE I THAT'S BE EIGHT
SEVENTY NINE FIVE A YEAR.
SO THEIR I SP EIGHT FOUR SIX
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CLEAR I ON THE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE CABALLERO
[inaudible]
WHERE I
AND WE OUR JOURNEYING BE FULL
BUDGET COMMITTEE